[Musique]
eric sadar bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle singer view est ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement
je suis écrivain et philosophe
et depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant une bonne quinzaine d'années
je analyse de près
tant d'un point de vue littéraire que
d'un point de vue théorique les
développements technologiques
qui sont caractérisées par la vitesse
incessantes la vitesse incessantes qui
qui nous démunies de notre
capacité à nous déterminer à être
conscients de ce qui se passe donc je
crois que en tout cas me concernant il y
va de mon devoir de d'aller voir de près
ce qui se joue de très près est-ce que
vous avez une formation de technicien
non non je ne crois tu pas je suis allé
voir
parfois des décodeurs dont expliquer des
choses mais je suis à l'affût
continuellement de ce qui se passe quoi
je fais dans les labos je veux voir les
choses de près
ses origines à nice et votre copain
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de du
rapport sur l'intelligence artificielle
ben vous avez remarqué que c'était
cynique satirique général j'ai bien j'ai
bien compris vous avez remarqué que
avant même de parler de villani
que l'intelligence artificielle fait
tourner la tête là depuis deux ans et
tout le monde parle que de cela je pense
qu'on n'a jamais autant dit de bêtises
d'inepties faut être plus familier
encore dans le terme relativement un
phénomène aussi déterminant
e
tout le monde donne son avis en général
en portant des intérêts particuliers ce
qui me posiez la question
maveety à me présenter ski notamment me
catégorise relativement à plein de gens
qui parlent sur la chose qu'on a un avis
sur la chose et qui véhiculent des
discours sur la chose c'est que
contrairement à tant de ces personnes
moi je ne parle à partir d'aucun intérêt
je suis dans une stricte indépendance
c'est pour ça que là puisque nous
parlons de villani voilà une personne
qui parle à partir d'intérêt et à tel
point d'intérêt qu'il est lui-même
député de la majorité présidentielle et
voilà un technicien qui est totalement
inféodée non seulement pouvoir
économique un scientifique un technicien
de mathématiciens non seulement inféodée
au pouvoir économique mais au pouvoir
politique mais sur cela je reviendrai
quand je disais et tant de bêtise
ce qui me gêne et c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire dans mon livre qui vient
de sortir merci pour l'invitation
si vous avez peut-être remarqué qu'on
parle
donc on dit beaucoup de choses c'est
qu'on parle beaucoup plus des effets ou
de quelques effets plutôt que de la
cause moi il me semble qu relativement
un phénomène aussi déterminant qui est
appelé à modifier de part en part et au
présent et plus encore à l'avenir nos
existences il s'agirait en société
d'aller voir ce qui se joue alors il ya
plein d'affaires qui nous prennent et
qui nous font paniquer à l'inter de
l'est la sempiternelle équation binaire
avantages supposés inconvénients
supposés ça fait remarquer que c'est
toujours à l'intérieur de cette équation
binaire qu'on envisage les choses de
laquelle moi je prends mes distances ou
profite d'une analyse de ce que je nomme
les les phénomènes majorité amont
structure je suppose que nous allons
mentale et donc à l'intérieur de cette
équation
binaire
on en
on essaie de
d'envisager les effets alors quand je
dis que samedi ce temps les affects
destruction du travail de métiers
notamment métier ou de compétences
cognitives alors c'est la panique totale
comme si c'était le seul supposé
inconvénients d'avoir les choses ne sont
pas passées exactement comme elles sont
dites et puis il ya quantité d'autres
effets qui ne sont jamais envisagé ce
que je fais dans mon livre et dont on va
parler je suppose et dans les supposés
avantages c'est toujours la même
histoire qu'ont eu cesse de ressasser
moi je suis allé voir que les choses ne
sont pas du tout comme elles sont
racontées racontée par des personnes qui
portent des intérêts à savoir les
supposés avantages
les développements et les bénéfices on
va tirer
les formidables bénéfices supposés dont
va tirer la médecine parler
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle ce qui est une sorte de
mascarade de l'heure je suis allé voir
ça de près alors là je parle des faits
dont on ne cesse de parler je pense
qu'il fallait voir la cause ce qui se
joue et ça personne ne le dit personne
ne le dit l'intelligence artificielle on
parle des effets c'est la panique
ouhlala grand objet de discussions de
unes de magazines de l'époque mais
personne essaye de comprendre qu'est ce
qui se joue
alors je veux lui dire précisément ce
qu'ils jouent ce show que nous avons
érigé l'humain ériger une instance à
nous dire la vérité en toute chose car
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire
de système d'intelligence artificielle
ce sont des systèmes d' expertise une
puissance expertise toujours plus plus
forte si toujours plus forte car ce sont
là des gens satisfaits de ce n'est pas
un état nous le savons ce sont c'est une
évolution en cours par les capacités
d'auto apprentissage par le machine
learning donc la capacité à 116
sophistiqué
la puissance d' expertise chez de
landing le machine learning céder des
capacités de
2 explique très précisément dans mon
livre c'est la capacité de
de
corrélation de prise en compte
continuelle des résultats précédents et
au vu des résultats
énoncer des jeux de réajustement
continuelle par
parler par les systèmes car nous vivons
une nouvel embranchement dans
dans l'histoire du numérique qui est
conquis et courtes et longues à la fois
quand je dis nouvel embranchement là je
suis toujours sur la nature de ce qui se
joue actuellement c'est que le numérique
et l'informatique depuis allé en en gros
la fin 19ème siècle et plus encore
depuis l'après guerre
c'est une instance qui a permis trois
choses la collecte de l'information le
sto gars le stockage et l'indexation et
qui permettait cette structure-là
des jeux de manipulation aisée de
l'information à diverses fins et
qui induisait des rapports en général
frontaux principalement tous les cas
depuis une cinquantaine d'années il ya
des écrans à l'information et qui
permettait à chacun en théorie d'anjou
et plus ou moins librement depuis une
dizaine d'années il ya un nouvel
embranchement qui se développe si cette
histoire là c'est sa disposition de
manipuler aisément de l'information ne
cesse de se développer et 7 ses
fonctionnalités continue
aujourd'hui j'ai presque envie dire il
ya plus qu'une nouvelle fonctionnalité
il ya une nouvelle mission qui est
affecté à des systèmes sessad expertise
et d etat du raid de nous dire de quoi
ils sont constitués de nous dire la
réalité des faits à des vitesses qui
dépasse infiniment nos capacités
cognitives et parfois de ne dire des la
réalité des faits
l'état de certaines situations
relativement à des choses qui étaient
ignorés à notre propre conscience par
exemple par exemple
un miroir d'y connecter
car aujourd'hui le miroir parle n'est ce
pas mehdi en fonction de l'analyse de
cette puissance d' expertise en fonction
de critères qui
sur lesquels il ya tant de choses à dire
sur les quais les aoûtats de revenir en
fonction de l'analyse de l'état de mon
visage des traits non lisa façon
évolutive me dit puissance d' expertise
puissance d'interprétation
prenez telle pilule ou tels compléments
alimentaires ou aller dans tel séjour à
la montagne en fonction de l'état de
votre visage donc cette puissance
d'interprétation
elle est plus à l'est pas seulement une
une puissance à nous dire l'état supposé
exacte des choses à nous dit la vérité
pourquoi je dis la vérité plutôt que
d'exactitude
parce que l'exactitude sadi un état des
choses il a fait beau le jour de
l'investiture de fahy la plupart dont le
jour de l'investiture de trains que le
20 juin le 20 janvier 2017 sanaa tâcher
de comme on lui dit qu'il a fait beau
pour enjoliver l'investiture non hidayat
passé c'est factuel il a fait il a plu
voilà ça c'est l'exactitude ou ça que
quand on parle de chef de poste vérité
etc je pense qu'on se trouve totalement
si l'afer d'exactitude pas du tout une
histoire de vérité en revanche toute
vérité a une valeur performative
pourquoi je dis ça parce que ça
l'intelligence artificielle a une valeur
performative c'est une puissance de
vérité par exemple l'exemple du du
miroir connectés elle me dit j'ai l'air
fatigué donc en retour ça induit des
gestes à engager en fonction de ce qui
est annoncé vous n'êtes pas obligé de
les suivre on n'est pas obligé déçu
alors c'est la question est très
intéressant car avec ce relativement à
ce que je viens de dire nous vivons ce
que j'explique de craie dans mon livre
le moment le tournant injonctive de la
technique c'est à dire c'est tout à fait
nouveau dans l'histoire de la technique
mais plus largement par l'histoire de
l'humanité que des systèmes techniques
nous dit d'agir de telle manière plutôt
que de telle manière alors ça se produit
à différents niveaux que j'essaie
d'analyser de près au delà de tous les
discours formaté au delà de toutes les
formules explique expéditive qu on ne
cesse d'entendre fallait voir de près
les différents niveaux injonctif les
niveaux que j'ai nommé incitatif sur
lequel je veux dire quelque chose au
pluriel qui s'applique principalement
aux individus un niveau que je nomme
impératif qui regardent des secteurs
d'organisation en commun un niveau que
je nomme prescriptif qui est à l'oeuvre
dans la médecine il est temps que nous
disions de près ce qui se joue dans la
médecine à l'écart du tout les discours
qui sont totalement fabriquées et qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
et un niveau coercitif c'est à l'oeuvre
dans le champ du travail est dans le
champ militaire alors vous disiez
incitatif on n'est pas tenu de les
suivre certes sauf que ce qu'il se passe
c'est que en peu de temps on peut de
temps nous sommes entrés dans un moment
où
des systèmes nous disent des choses par
exemple pour nous les individus car vous
remarquerez qu moment la technique et
doté du pouvoir de nous dire la vérité
c'est très troublant elle est dotée du
pouvoir de parole serait très troublant
c'est une couche c'est une conjonction
historique on ne sait pas si c'est
prémédité aussi c'est une sorte de
lazard la technique nous parle regardez
les anciens de connecter à genoux par
j'ouvre une parenthèse
imaginez vous vous avez une montre
connectés ou votre connecter un censeur
sur vous et ce censeur vous préviens que
vous êtes en train de faire des
extrasystoles et qu'il faudrait
peut-être aller à l'hôpital se faire
monitorat de près par un toubib lui-même
assisté d'intelligence artificielle
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien alors moi
je suis je me mets au delà du bien et du
mal j'essaie d'avoir d'avoir ce qu'ils
se prennent dès ce qui se joue de presse
qu est ce que c est ce que certains vous
reprochent de techno fond mais il s'agit
pas du tout cela c'est salle j 2 de
saisir d'abord que la technique puisque
technophobes ne veut rien dire c'est
comme technophiles la technique n'existe
plus la technique n'existe plus alors
les gens vont dire mais de quoi il parle
technique n'existe plus oui la technique
en tant que champ relativement autonome
composée de serveurs de techniciens
d'ingénieurs
animé par des intérêts divers nulle part
des tropismes multiples tout cela est
terminé aujourd'hui les ingénieurs les
programmeurs les techniciens les
scientifiques cédric villani en premier
temps d'autres sont inféodés aux
intérêts économiques et son affaire
inféodés au monde de l'industrie donc
moi je suis ni technophobes ni le
technophile j'essaye de voir ce que le
techno économique induit sur nos
existences car nous vivons aujourd'hui
dans un moment où la technique qui voit
les développements déterminé uniquement
dans leur quasi dans la grande majorité
dans l'ue économique par des intérêts
déterminée par des intérêts économiques
des cabinets tendance ou des
départements marketing industrie et ça
c'est un drame c'est un drame parce que
c'est la pluralité de la technique c'est
la pluralité de formes de techniques qui
sont neutralisés au profit de
développement qui s'inscrivent dans la
même direction dans la même trajectoire
dont on me dit d'abord quality n'est que
ces trajectoires sont inéluctables et
dont on ne voit pas qu'elle réponde à
deux visées principal sa personne ne lui
dit voir de près ça et ça leur affirme
haut et fort ses développements
technologiques répondent c'est l'état
actuel notamment l'intelligence
artificielle de tunisie qu'il faut
mobiliser toutes les forces invité tous
les chercheurs étrangers en france que
nous soyons un paul que macro ont dit
que c'était avec 1.5 milliards d'euros
qu'on a fait un grand show voilà avec il
faut qu'il faut qu'il faut que ça la
france devienne un pôle de l'ia mais
avant d'agir dans cette précipitation
comprends ton ce qui se joue avant de
dire comme laurent alexandre qui dit lui
aussi inepties sur inepties qu'on est en
retard qui répète toujours les mêmes
conneries en boucle la chine va être
devant les états unis vont très vite et
nous on est à la traîne on est à la
traîne de quoi on est à la traîne de
quel modèle de société un modèle de
société qui vise à quantifier par des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
continuellement d existence et à nous
suggérer continuellement des offres de
services et de produits supposés
adaptées à chacun à chaque instant de
notre quotidien c'est ce modèle
économique cette puissance d' expertise
d'interprétation de comportement en vue
de temps vers devises et donc j'y
reviens sur cd musical son talent en vue
de faire entrer le libéralisme dans un
nouveau seuil ce que je nomme le techno
libéralisme qui vise à interpréter en
continu nos comportements qui permettent
à des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle interpréter via des
capteurs des téléphones
les les cadets les capteurs dans le
domicile les enceintes connectés ça ne
suffisait pas de le suivre nos
navigations internet nos usages sur les
applications il fallait maintenant en
plus interpréter nos paroles
les paroles échangées au sein du
domicile même les téléviseurs connectés
depuis quelques années et est doté de
cette fonctionnalité donc la guerre
aujourd'hui économique la guerre
industrielle c'est ce que je nomme la
conquête du comportemental 1 il s'agit
de il s'agit de collecter de plus en
plus d'informations relativement à à nos
comportements en vue de quoi et c'est là
que l'intelligence artificielle vient
s'agréger à cette structure techno
économique en vue car l'alternance
artificielle vous le savez c'est une
puissance interprétative mais aussi
capable de créer 3 giran fonctions
d'interprétation et de nous dire et de
nous dire
continuellement c'est ça l'enjeu
économique de dire continuellement au
long de quotidiens
je me lève le gui à des puces plus des
puces
nimal mais des puces de silicium
interprète mon sommeil il ya même des
bandeaux qui interprète le sommeil je
vais dans la salle de bains l'étoile est
de connecter la salle de bains connecter
le miroir connectée la maison et tout à
l'avenant ce soir dans la ville tout est
à l'avenant donc l'idée ce qui n'est
plus de coups de rupture de faisceau
dans la clac la collecte des
informations relativement à nos
comportements mais pas en vue nous
surveiller nous ne sommes plus du tout
dans la primauté de la surveillance de
laquelle tout le monde se gausse en
disant oh là là je surveillais 7,7 cette
propension victimaire non il s'agit pas
du tout de cela cg de collecter des
informations
relativement à des actions de plus en
plus étendue de nos quotidiens et qui
permettent et c'est là que
l'intelligence artificielle intervient
qui permettent à des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle de
continuellement vu de l'interprétation
de nos état
physique est de plus en plus
physiologique avec ce qui est nommé un
telle informatique émotionnelle car il
s'agit pas seulement d'interpréter nos
gestes mais aussi d'aller jusqu'au fond
notre psy quai à terme avec cette
abjection d'informatique de
l'informatique émotionnel il s'agit de
pouvoir continuellement nous dire nous
dire nous accompagner c'est comme ça
cette enseigne qu'il faut comprendre des
assistants personnels numériques à
l'efficacité encore balbutiante c'était
à cette enseigne qu'il faut comprendre
les enceintes connecter avec qui nous
dialoguons pas en vue de nous raconter
je ne sais quoi mais ont vu de un moment
ou un autre continuellement interpréter
nos états et un moment ou un autre nous
signaler des offres supposé appropriée à
chacun de nos instants donc là la liste
pourrait être longue peut-être parlerons
nous c'est extraordinaire cette histoire
de voiture autonome il faut que nous en
parlions un moment ce qui se joue c'est
que de l'intelligence artificielle
d'intelligence à la voiture autonome
mais là donc je parle de visées
commerciales de la technique c'est à
dire que toute cette structure
technologies elle supporte à nouveau
moment du libéralisme que je nomme
techno libéraliste qui veut qu'il n'y
ait plus d espace vacant entre vous moi
chacun de nous et les grands groupes de
l'industrie de la donne et qui entend
diriger comme les plateformes entre
chacun de nous et les compagnies du
monde entier en vue de soi elle même de
proposer des produits en fonction de
l'interprétation de comportement soit de
s'ériger comme les plates-formes
indispensable pour entre toutes les
compagnies du monde et sa canne nous qui
par l'achat de mots clés
les grandes plateformes les mettent en
relation avec chacun de nous ça c'est
une visée cette visée de de monétiser la
connaissance de chacun de comportement
mais la deuxième mise et c'est une
vision du monde aussi une vision du
monde qui entend c'est particulièrement
le cas dans le secteur du travail qui
entend organiser de façon
algorithmique de plus en plus optimisée
des séquences
de nos quotidiens principalement des
secteurs d'organisation collective la
vident le champ du travail
7 l'intelligence artificielle est un et
ça on ne le voit pas suffisamment est un
formidable instrument visant à
rationaliser plus que jamais c'est un
facteur de rationalisation c'est à dire
de l'organisation
sans faille de secteurs d'organisation
en commun nous parleront peut-être cible
et je vous parle dès maintenant de ce
qui se passe dans la data jewel
manufacture ce qui est exactement le cas
et c'est un vecteur de
d'instauration thamond dire pour être
très précis
d'une vision extrêmement utilitariste du
monde et de la société
alors je fais je vais je vais dérouler
plus précisément des choses que j'ai dit
là mais vous entendre vous comprenez
quand j'entends continuellement les
macron les vilenies et tant d'autres
dire nous sommes en retard l'europe n'a
investi pas assez la france n'investit
pas assez il faut que le mode mais
lisions tous les chercheurs du monde
entier mais sait-on ce qui se joue au
nom de quoi c'est à dire que au nom des
sacro saint point de croissance au nom
d'une idéologie qui s'est formée en tpr
est pas très très peu de temps
qui veut que
la grande cause nationale dans tous les
pays c'est l'investissement dans
l'intelligence artificielle que tout
cela s'opère dans la précipitation à tel
point que notre cher secrétaire d'état à
l'économie numérique mounir medjoubi dit
il a dit dans le monde il ya trois
semaines un dossier dans le monde sur
éthique et il y alors l'éthique la
hausse y aura tant de choses à dire s'il
serait peut-être qu'on en dira quelques
mots cette grande imposture de notre
temps ce vague pour ce grand fourre tout
je me mouille et en mahdjoubi a dit
qu'il comprend donc ministre de la
république quand même de la république
française entendez bien ce que je vais
dire parce que je vais dire vous avez
cités il a dit qu'il comprend bien que
on agit et que les industries à l'avancé
puis on réfléchira après mais moi je
dirais à ce monsieur mais ils seront la
république qu'il est temps que ces
enjeux fasse l'objet de débats et merci
de m'avoir invité ce soir l'objet de
débat à la hauteur des enjeux que la
société se saisisse de ces enjeux et que
nous voyons les modes les la vision du
monde qui est à l'oeuvre c'est celle de
la monétisation de tous nos
comportements d'une marchandisation
intégrale de la vie et d'une
organisation
algorithmique de la société nous allons
préciser je suppose comment les choses
se perd mais déjà jeudi dès maintenant
dès maintenant sans attendre que là il
s'agit pour moi d'une société d'une
vision du monde que je désapprouve mais
plus que je les appeaux que je trouve
abject et qui va à l'encontre de tous
les principes qui nous fonde lesquels le
sel de la de de l'humanisme de
l'autonomie du jugement delà de la
liberté de nous déterminer en conscience
et quoi l'autonomie de jumeaux quid du
libre exercice de notre faculté de
jugement absolument et le respect de la
pluralité
absolument c'est ça absolument mais eric
je te coupe ils aient confiance ou pub
pour exercer son libre exercice de
facultés de jugement c'est pas le peuple
c'est la figure human j'ai dû le peuple
ce que tu appelles le peuple qu'on peut
nommer le peuple actuellement
relativement à ces enjeux cette
puissance technico économique il ya des
formes d'appétit il ya des formes de non
confiance moi je parle pas du peuple je
parle de la famille la figure humain ce
qui le caractérise
nous sommes des êtres de jugement nous
sommes des êtres d'après ce d'après
d'appréhension multisensorielle du réel
nous sommes des êtres c'est ça la
conquête humaniste je n'ai encore une
parenthèse eu d'accord avec toi mais
mais le résultat s'est coincé on a une
terre qui est dégueulasse il ya du bout
de plastique partout l'objectif c'est
consommer encore plus tout le temps de
consommer fond et puis quand on n'est
pas content parce que le prix de
l'essence à rapa on va manifester avec
son petit gilet jaune le 10 septembre
alors que 60 ou 70 % de la masse des
espèces est en train de disparaître donc
c'est ça que c'est il faut continuer là
dedans il faut un peu rationaliser grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle des
comportements humains a certainement pas
certainement pas déjà il fait l'avocat
du diable bien évidemment à tous j'ai
bien compris non déjà il faut saisir à
quel point mais ça ça nous savons
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est une chose
que nous savons maintenant très
clairement depuis quelques années c'est
une des consciences qui commencent à
apparaître avec l'un des genres ratifié
malheureusement ça a lieu ô combien
c'est que le régime privé s'est saisi de
société c'est prévu s'est saisi du
développement de l'évolution du cours de
société le monde économique
ledit saisie ou la laisser faire alors
les très bonnes questions les deux et
d'une soumission consentie à ilian il y
a une
une soumission du monde politique à ses
développements économiques à ces
développements techniques ou économiques
il ya une telle soumission
que
il y aurait tant de choses à dire quand
on parle de régulation ça me fait rire
c'est il ya beaucoup de choses qui me
met en colère aujourd'hui beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup depuis quelques années
je touche un peu ramé oui j'avais quand
quand on parle d'intelligence
artificielle
il ya des bonnes âmes
alors qu il dit il faudra un peu
d'éthique ce qu'ils correspondent
absolument à rien c'est à l'éthique
c'est devenu une sorte d'abstraction de
grand fourre tout ce sont les mêmes qui
développent ces systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle qui parle d'éthique à tout
bout de champ sur les ingénieurs qui
sont inféodés au monde économique qui a
tout le temps à leur bouche parle
d'éthique continuellement 1 je pense à
jean gabriel ghanassia qui a écrit en
plus ces gens là écrivent à face et
ingénieurs qui sont inféodés par le
monde économique qui ont sont totalement
qui ont démissionné sur leurs plus tueur
critique et crée écrivent des livres
pour nous dire tout cela est formidable
mais attention il faut être vigilant
et il faut faire preuve d'éthique salon
sema pas de quoi il parle ni de quoi on
parle aujourd'hui quand par des tic dont
qu'ils écrivent en général est très très
mauvais libre il faut dire la vérité des
trésors du torchon où il ferait mieux de
passer de demander à des bons [__] a
des bons actifs de les écrire sur la
lune c'est déjà le cas en lui son vin
doux qu'un nommé ses livres sont des
torchons les livres de gamme dacia sont
des torchons sedan laurence de lillers
et des torchons il ya une quête et des
torchons qui a ils disent tous la même
chose il ce qui te reproche d'être le
bhl du numérique aux énormes et ça c'est
et ce n'est pas très important ça c'est
mais je continue sur cette histoire de
car il ya tellement discours qui
polluent l'espace public moi j'essaye à
ma mesure non pas de dépolluer mais
d'être un peu à l'écart de cette
pollution et ces gens là ils participent
c'est à dire d'écrire des torchons pour
nous dire que nous allons vers des
vérins un monde
formidable il faut être un peu vigilants
oui il faut être vigilant car on va
faire preuve d'éthique c'est à dire est
que cesser ces entreprises là toutes les
entreprises les gaffes à etc ils ont
tous des comités d'éthique à l'intérêt
c'est à mourir de rire c'est la personne
ne relève ça ils parlent tous des tic
mais d'abord c'est le le chien aboie la
caravane passe et ça ne produit
absolument rien et quand on parle pas
des tic on parle de régulation mais
quelle mais quelle blague c'est à dire
on a en un rapport à la règle sion pour
parler au monde politique
on a un rapport à la régulation qui
voudrait que l'état le législateur dans
quantité de champs de la vie humaine
nous protégerait de certaines dérives
mais c'est à mourir de merde qu'elle
dirige mais c'est à mourir de rire
aujourd'hui nous vivons dans un régime
juridique et l'ordo libéralisme c'est à
dire les lois sont écrites en vue de
développer de soutenir le développement
du monde économique tous les désastres
dont tu évoquais le législateur écrit
des loin en vue de le soutenir les
législateurs au lieu de prendre
conscience c'est pourquoi dès ce qui se
joue mais je pense qu'ils répondent aux
sacro-saints à la nécessité de
satisfaire les intérêts au taux
économique et qu ils répondent vraiment
à la maison il ya une explication
beaucoup plus simple que ça du moins
j'espère oui
si le système économique se vautre si on
entre dans une décroissance du système
bancaire se [__] et tout le monde se
vautre probablement probablement c'est
une fuite en avant
c'est pas qu'une fuite en avant ses ils
ont besoin d'une canne numérique pour
optimiser cette fuite en avant oui
est-ce que je vais au fond de ta pensée
oui mais je dirais
vrac on reparle de ce qui tue et joue
encore dans les faits avec notre
intelligence artificielle je dirais oui
tu as raison mais je dirais aussi qu'il
ya une telle doxa linthal doxa tellement
puissante qui impose des discours moi je
pense que nous vivons l'ère de la
puissance qu'est ce que je vais dire
l'art de la puissance vous savez on
compare souvent
les gaffes ou maintenant les groupes
chinois les grands groupes de
l'industrie numérique avec les états
mais ça n'a aucun sens c'est pas du tout
ça là encore voir des clichés qui sait
être rebattues qui n'ont qu'un sens
sommes à l'ère de la puissance où il ya
de nombreuses puissances enfin il y en a
quelques-unes et à la puissance des
états elles existent quand ce jusqu'à
nouvel ordre aya amazon vient pas
perturber l'état l'état français l'état
allemand n'en n'ont ce sont des des
puissances parallèle qui est qui où il
ya des effets des mictions y les
rapports de force et pas assez bon il ya
la puissance militaire il ya des
puissances militaires il ya des
puissances nucléaires et puis à des
puissances industrielles unc et il ya la
puissance de l'industrie numérique qui
est devenu sans cesse plus puissant
depuis une vingtaine d'années et à l'ère
de la puissance à tel point que à telle
enseigne que ces deux les gens qui ont
créé ces groupes là pour la plupart
enfin pour certains d'entre eux ils sont
ils sont intelligents certes mais ils
ont le tournis enfin ils sont venus se
sont pris de vertige ils sont sont une
sorte de sentiment de toute puissance en
tout cas il on a compris de mégalomanie
de mégalomanie me mène de psychiatrie
regarde regarde brusque tel ce la fin
bon mais c'est pas ça donc je veux
parler là ils ont compris que il fallait
imposer
il fallait imposer des discours il
fallait il fallait banaliser les
développements et les modes les modes
d'organisation
qui sont induits par les développements
auxquels ils oeuvrent alors
avez vous remarqué depuis une dizaine
d'années une nouvelle race est apparue
nouvelle race hassan interpelle
personnes une nouvelle race qui a paru
dans l'espace public c'est les
évangélistes de l'industrie du numérique
a alors ces gens là ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux ils sont payés mais tout
le monde n'est pas payée il y en a qui
reprennent qui prennent le relais de ces
paroles et qui imposait discours partout
et qui imposait discours dans les médias
un qui impose les discours dans les
universités qui a posé discours auprès
du législateur qui imposait discours
dans les écoles d'ingénieurs qui
voudraient ses discours qui voudrait que
les développements en cours
technologique techno donc
techno-économique
si on les obtient par le bon bout donc
toujours avec les délires avec un peu
des pieds qu'avec un peu de régulation
tout ce blabla à trois balles contre
lesquels il faut s'opposer parce que ça
ça interdit de voir ce qui se joue
exactement ces gens-là occupe le
discours ce qui se joue c'est quoi ces
l'asservissement des pauvres se joue je
veux dire très simplement ce qui se joue
c'est la pression à plusieurs niveaux
sur la décision humain c'est à dire que
la façon dont nous agissons
individuellement et collectivement est
appelée à être de plus en plus pressée
orienté encadrait
déterminé à plusieurs niveaux un dock
des niveaux de de la jonction de plus en
plus fort vu déterminé en vue de
soi satisfaire des intérêts économiques
soit instauré une vision de la société
de plus en plus rationalisée où on
voudrait que le moindre défaut soient
évacués il était temps que mais qu' il
était temps un espace au vu de haut vues
de notre imperfection fondamental de
toutes les bêtises du chaos du monde un
miracle a lieu aujourd'hui un miracle a
lieu
des systèmes technologiques mais ce
terme technologique m'agace des systèmes
technico-économique 1 et des systèmes
techniques aux pôles politiques
technico économiques politiques sont
destinées à encadrer
le cours des affaires humain alors
auprès des individus au près les
affaires collectives
doc c'est c'est la décision humain alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la décision
avant que tu commences à te lancer oui
est-ce que c'est peut-être vachement
bien
regarde regarde je jalouse je vais je
vais être cynique qui vous fait encore
l'avocat du diable mais quand tu vois
cette masse de crétins
dépolluer partout en avoir rien à [__]
de tout être égoïste c'est ça mène
l'humanité à sa fin les océans sont
complètement âgées lyon se tartine
autant de crème solaire à fond on
s'achète encore des plus grosses
bagnoles toulouse - rennes à [__]
peut-être que le père classe de mégalo
travaillant à silicon valley s'est dit
on va leur faire un petit cheval de
troie on va les encadrer hop et puis
comme ça on sera tranquille c'est pas
mal moins bien ça mais l'expression
cheval de troie j'ai oublié d'apporter
là elle est pas belle la vie elle est
magnifique la une de triche pas
t'énerver avec janna non mais comme tu
le dit d'un point de vue ironique je
vois bien que c'est pas c'est pas un
vent opposé à ce que je dis mais tu as
utilisé l'expression intéressante cheval
de troie
il ya eu la une n'a plus je pense la
plus belle une sur l'intelligence
artificielle dans le monde et à deux
semaines c'était à l'occasion de la
sortie de mon livre on a fait une grande
entretien
pour politis que je lis pas mais la une
de politis de match folle et la partage
été oubliée chez moi mais deux personnes
peuvent la voir il ya deux semaines et
alors à l'écart de toutes les unes
de time magazine love c'est toute la
presse du monde entier les dangers de
l'intelligence artificielle ou l'avenir
de l'intelligence artificielle et tout
c'est une avec des des formules sans
s'être battus ils ont ils ont ils ont
titré de façon extrêmement pertinente
l'intelligence artificielle le cheval de
troie du techno libéralisme il était
temps il était temps il est étonnant de
voir que l'intelligence artificielle
c'est une
chance extraordinaire
pour le libéralisme c'est une chance
inouïe c'est pour ça qu'il ya tant
d'investissements c'est l'intelligence
et une chance inouïe qui vise à
continuellement à la fois optimisé les
modes de production dans le monde de
l'entreprise parce que cela aussi c'est
aussi ça l'intelligence artificielle car
nous nous parlons continuellement alors
là il ya les affects c'est la panique
des destructions annoncées d'emploi
c'est d'abord c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ce qu'on dit mais nous ne
parlons pas du tout mais ça je suis allé
voir de près dans mon livre les nouveaux
modes de management induits par la
toujours sortie est ce que tu as été
voir ça mais je suis allé voir dans les
entreprises tranquille l'ancien qui
n'ont droit mais je les clés des laits
et conseillers d'accenture je les
connais très bien qui conseille toutes
les entreprises du monde entier edit bm
et ds ap tu connais ça paie 1 alors
qu'est-ce qu'il conseille tous ces gens
là qui font du consulting pour toutes
les grosses entreprises du monde je le
redis précisément pour qu'on comprenne
bien de quoi nous parlons destructions
d'emplois c'est la panique chez les
affectent mais il ya quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sournois qu'on ne voit pas
qui sont les modes management
c'est-à-dire les modes d'organisation en
commun dans l'entreprise alors je vais
préciser je vais déterminé je vais
définir en quelques mots comment ça se
passe en temps comment ça se passe
car l'architecturé technico économique
est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui c'est la
conjonction entre deux facteurs
techniques quand je dis technique on a
compris que ses technico économique ne
vais pas leur dire à chaque fois la
conjonction de deux facteurs qui et les
capteurs sur nos sur des surfaces de
plus en plus étendu nos réalités et les
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle des
capteurs qui collectent des données et
qui est des synthés des systèmes
d'intelligence sociale qui interprète
des situations de plus en plus en temps
réel car nous sommes dans une autre
politique du temps réel et qui font pas
que des retraités ça vous est
interprétée ont duré bon ok les
interprètes et zohra qui détermine en
retour des actions entreprendre soit ce
sont les systèmes eux-mêmes qui engagent
des actions de façon automatisée soit
des systèmes et dicte au signal à des
humains les actions supposés les plus
pertinentes à entreprend alors le monde
dans l'entreprise ce qui est nommé de
façon hyper sexy d'attac manufacture ça
fait ça sonne très sexy comme ça
l'entreprise piloté par la donner un
faux de fois faut l'inventer celle-là
dont dont tous les politiques et tous
les grands industriels et accenture et
ibm et tous les grands groupes ne cesse
de d'asséner est de faire en sorte et de
mobiliser les moyens pour aller vers
cette date azzurri veulent manufacture
moi je pensais que les entreprises
étaient des collectifs humain où il y
avait des humains qui travaillent
ensemble au vu d' intérêt plus ou moins
communs dans la dans la contradiction
dans du conflit mais qui
qui plus ou moins ensemble essaye de
produire les résultats qui sont qui sont
souhaitées maintenant c'est les usines
qui sont pilotés par la donner alors ça
il faut l'entendre qu'il ya de l'action
humaine qui est piloté par la donne et
qu'est ce que c'est et puis le départ
l'a donné c'est qu'il ya des capteurs
dans le monde dans l'entreprise sur les
chaînes sur le département de conception
comment qu'on soit chaude c'est évaluer
en temps réel sur les chaînes de
production
sur les chaînes logistiques sur les
chaînes de transport jusqu'à ce qui est
nommé satisfaction client et qu'est-ce
que ça induit cela ça induit qu'il y a
une visibilité en temps réel de ce qui
est nommé mesure de performance du
personnel comme on dit en management
mais qui font pas que mesurer les
performances du personnel ça le 6 mai
lors d'une façon continue précise
ininterrompue mais si avec cette
abjection on dirait bon palet il ya une
connaissance de mes gestes mais non il
ya des systèmes qui en fonction de cette
connaissance exacte en retour des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle qui
sont en train d'être implanté dans la
plupart des grandes entreprises du monde
entier soutenu par accenture mobilisés
et qui bénéficie de fonds publics
notamment en france sur cc cc cette
usine point 4.0 là encore ça sonne très
sexy et qui voit donc par cette
structure technologique avec les six ont
vraiment dire au personnel à l'aide
entre les casques audio d'amazones un
des casques audio damage il n'y a pas
que amazonia plein d'entreprises qui
voit du personnel réduit des des êtres
de chair de sang réduits à des à des
robots qui répondent à quoi qui
répondent à des signaux c'est à dire
qu'ils sont démunis de toute spontanéité
subjectivité inventivité c'est cela qui
est à l'oeuvre notamment dans
l'organisation commune des affaires
humaines par des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle et alors vous entendez les
maquereaux et viviani qui dit il faut
plus encore investir dans l'intelligence
artificielle mais c'est une honte c'est
une honte tu vois pas du tout
l'intelligence artificielle tous ces
capteurs tout ce que tu aimes d'écrire
comme une opportunité pour nous pour
avoir plus de temps ça va nous faire
gagner du temps on va avoir une
meilleure qualité de vie on va vivre
plus longtemps on va avoir une société
plus performante avec avec peut-être
l'opportunité de revenir sur notre
propre humanité non je crois que sur ce
que tu dis là qui est encore assez
ironique j'entends bien mais pas que
pour mon sens à une équation très simple
un pour répondre à ce que la question
que tu pauthe s'est dès qu'il ya des
systèmes qui nous dessaisisse de notre
pouvoir
de jugement de notre pouvoir d'action de
ne pouvoir de décider librement sans
subir de pression du cours de nos
affaires individuelles et collectives
c'est inacceptable dès qu'il y a des
pouvoirs des fonctionnalités paraguay ce
qu'on comprenne bien de quoi nous
parlons oui waze racheté par google à la
sarre tapisserie en dix ans et demi
voilà donc et qui qui qui qui signale en
temps réel l'état du trafic
bon avec des pas connaissance des
comportements de là où je vais
géolocalisation bon mais ça on connaît
par coeur ce la mémoire utilisée
je vais pas raconter d'histoires c'est
pratique mais avec ça je fais ce que je
veux bien se fiche que je rentrais de
roissy à un moment je ne suis pas très
fait confiance j'ai dit aux taxis besoin
j'aurais pu dire reprenons le prenant le
bon le chemin indiqué parce que en
théorie je fais ce que je veux avec
cette c3 formation mais avec la
sophistique est ce qu il faut bien
saisir ce qu'il faut bien saisir c'est
que nous sommes arrivés à ériger des
systèmes qui vont continuellement
éclairé de leurs lumières alors les
lumières du 21e siècle plus fin du
xviiie siècle
malheureusement éclairé de leur lumière
les bonnes entrées guillemets actions
entreprendre continuellement alors nous
avons dit tout à l'heure et tu l'as dis
toi même
je fais ce que je veux qu'on ça me
regarde d'un point de vue incitatif 1 je
fais ce que je veux dans l'entreprise
ont fait pas ce qu'on veut
dans le recrutement
on fait pas ce qu'on veut car le système
d'intelligence artificielle système d'
expertise à dire la vérité avez vous
relevé que depuis deux ans c'est très
récent
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
avec des chocs dialogue avec des
candidats
et disent toujours cette faculté à dire
la vérité une vérité donc à engager des
actions en conséquence je sélectionne
ses systèmes en fonction de dialogue
totalement débile de questions
totalement débile demandé aux candidats
je renvoie la plateforme puis soit les
pires empires et metric soupiré metrics
de 2,2 de sélection de candidats par des
tchats botte c'est d'une débilité
confondante à l ac le résultat
l'innovation des start up qui invente
des nouveaux modes de recrutement qui
sont sur une forme d'abjection bon bref
bénin réductionniste à dire qu'on a
affaire aux candidats qui est des
entretiens vidéo ou des relations et des
dialogues avec des tchats bottes bref et
qui disent voilà tel candidat qu'il faut
prendre qui disent la vérité et là on
nous dit mais l'humain est encore dans
la boucle au final c'est le cd
recruteurs qui vont
qui vont décider au final eur en 2018
oui et là nous sommes en plein dans la
fable de la complémentarité homme
machine là aussi qu'on essaye de
ressasser moi je voulais voir de près
une fable la complémentarité aux
machines c'est une femme de plus en plus
tard le match in learning parler de la
capacité d'auto apprentissage c'est la
puissance des expertises qui va sans
cesse sophistiqué et avec cette
sophistication sans cesse croissante les
résultats des équations qui vont être
énoncé voiliers de plus en plus fiables
qui répondent à des intérêts mais vont
être de plus en plus fiables
donc cette puissance a à nous dire faire
telles actions plutôt que telle action
c'est ce qui est appelé à j'ai envie de
dire s'instaurer je vais plus loin
encore à s'instituer dans nos existences
je vais plus loin encore à se banaliser
se banaliser le fait que à divers
niveaux on va nous dire valve a fait ça
dans le cadre du travail est telle
action plutôt que telle action dans le
cas du recrutement il ya des systèmes
selon des critères dont on ne sait rien
qui vise
la plus haute efficacité
le refus de tout défaut pour les tel
candidat plutôt que tel autre candidat
des systèmes qui dans le monde de la
justice avec la robotisation la justice
c'est la quantité d'exemples que j'ai
analysé dans mon livre qu'il faut aller
voir qui détermine aujourd'hui qui peut
être mis en liberté conditionnelle ou
non c'est cela aussi l'intelligence
artificielle dans le monde de la justice
on chope des terreaux istres
par exemple mais aussi
comment des prêts bancaires peuvent être
octroyées à des clients en fonction
d'historique de critères extrêmement
restreint il nous allons plus mauvais ça
non nous allons garder le problème du
crédit américain qui nous a foutu dans
la merde parce qu'il y avait des
conseillers bancaires qui vendait des
crédits à des personnes qui était comble
pas insolvable oui sauf que sauf que
dans la rade dans le temps dans la
banque c'est pareil pour le recrutement
jusqu'à récemment il y avait des des
rapports entre personnes
il y avait du dialogue il y avait on
peut le croire en théorie maintenant que
tu as porté par une banda normes et la
prise en compte du contexte pour
l'octroi de prêts par exemple pareil
pour le recrutement
qui jusque-là relevé de dialogue de
conversation de prise en compte de
facteurs multiples de facteurs aussi
indicible 1le
l'intuition humaine
ce sont de plus en plus des voix c'est
quoi l'intuition humaine pour toi
l'intervention humaine ce sont des
billets de la big data que tu comprends
pas sinon nous ont battu sion humaine
c'est des quantités de des dimensions
dont nous sommes dotés dont nous sommes
pourvus
qu'ils échappent à la catégorisation et
c'est cette intuition human qui est
appelée de plus en plus à être éradiqué
au profit des systèmes qui sont
réductionniste comme une appréhension
réductionniste erreur quand on ne peut
pas tout réduire à des données et qui
ces systèmes réductionniste vont
encadrer l'action humain car c'est aussi
une vision non seulement on en a parlé
utilitariste du monde où chaque
interprétation du situation doit faire
l'objet d'une action chaque action doit
faire l'objet chatte interprétation doit
faire l'objet d'une action en
conséquence et ça que je nomme
utilitariste soit une opération
marchande un exemple un exemple
d'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle que que tu souhaiterais
qu'ils pourraient apporter des bienfaits
l'humanité oui un exemple ah bah alors
là tu parles d'une chauve très sympa moi
j'ai un exemple oui mais moi je vais te
donner un exemple mais après tu vas voir
il ya différents niveaux lire les
mensonges politiques sur leurs visages
dans la norme et tu as vu le système aux
frontières pour détecteur de mensonges
voilà les anglais les anglais sir
l'aviation ils ont beau mais je vais
répondre à ta question ou à ta réflexion
watermark
à langage déjà à
pouvoir faire le tri c'est à dire de de
dire il ya peut-être des des
fonctionnalités d'intelligence
artificielle dont on pourrait servir et
qui pourrait être qui pourrait être allé
utile ou en prison en tout cas bienvenue
alors je vais t'en donner un traître et
un très bon exemple c'est à dire que
nous on ne les choses se passent
actuellement comme si tous les
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle donc la transformation
numérique de toutes les entreprises de
la société du monde et maintenant
aujourd'hui au moyen notamment de
systèmes intelligence artificielle et l
horizon lumineux est inéluctable d'une
société d'antan avec des développements
et des applications qui sont supposés
s'adosser à tous les secteurs de nos
vies avons nous les moyens de faire le
tri de dire ça on n'en veut pas et ça
tient c'est plutôt bénéfique je donne un
exemple
donc là je parle de la capacité à faire
le tri c'est à dire le graal à ne pas
prendre toutes les choses comme si
c'était entendu et relever de l'évidence
faire un peu preuve d'esprit critique et
du soupçon nietzschéen quand même de ne
pas être béat devant les paroles de tous
ces discours dos je le redis qui
polluent l'atmosphère les discours d'un
laurent alexandre polluent l'atmosphère
les discours dans cédric villani
polluent l'atmosphère parce qu'ils ne
sont doté d'aucun les discours d'un des
jambes raides ghanassia ou leur ange de
billère qui développe la l'informatique
émotionnel affective des robots a fait
kim et moi j'en veux pas de vos robots
affectif pour mieux s'occuper de ma
grand mère je m'en occupe toi même comme
jeune robot c'est une objection vous
histoire après vous parlez d'éthique
né en développer d'autres
restructurations technique alors là on
pourrait entendre c'est pas quand il ya
le feu dans la forêt a parlé d'éthique
et apprendre des seaux d'eau pour on
était un peu dans la forêt développé à
d'autres restructurations techniques à
d'autres productions technique alors là
on pourra parler d'éthique un là on
pourra parler d'éthique donc je donne un
bon exemple
c'est bien je suis en forme avec avec
toi avec think of view ce soir parce
qu'on en a marre d'entendre tous ces
discours qui je le redis qui sont
formatés qui sont qui sont véhiculés en
vue de satisfaire des intérêts 1 alors
je parle là nous allons parler d'un d'un
secteur déterminant déterminant à
l'exemple je sais je suis dans l'exemple
je vais te donner secteur déterminant
car
tout le monde aujourd'hui d'aider des
personnes ou des ingénieurs ou des
personnes qui développent ces systèmes
sont mises en critique ou un peu mis
sous le sceau du soupçon ce qui est très
rare mais quand ça arrive
il dégaine une arme imparable la
médecine voilà un secteur dont n'en
doutons pas nous allons tous bénéficié
il ya une personne qui ne cesse de dire
ça qui connaît rien en médecine gilles
babinet maintenant mais j'imagine et
j'en parle même pas voilà encore
quelqu'un qui colline parce que vous vu
l'atmosphère avec une gentille gilles
damez les gentils je joue bien c'est un
copain mais qui ne parlent que nom
d'intérêts privés moi je vous le redis
je pars le nom de maastricht indépendant
et de principe auxquels je crois que la
médecine alors non mais je vais jouer
avant je parle d'une personne qui nous
parle que de médecine mais qui n'y
connaît rien c'est qu'ils n'ont médiane
le cas yann le qu'un boss du labo dia à
facebook qui partout alors lui il occupe
dutil occupe du terrain dans les médias
partout nous dit la médecine ça va
sauver des vies il est pas du tout dans
la médecine mais pourquoi nous raconte
pas ce qu'il fait sur facebook jamais il
n'en parle regardez toutes les
interviews jamais à on comprendrait
mieux ce qui se joue si par exemple
monsieur le qu'un data scientiste non
shafia
auprès de facebook nous raconter cette
volonté d'interpréter de façon toujours
plus approfondie affiner les
comportements en vue d'instaurer une
relation client ininterrompue mais ça
ils s'en cache bien il n'en parle pas il
nous parle de médecine une petite
parenthèse avec yann le cas je suis
invitée dans une émission de télévision
la semaine prochaine je tairai le nom 1
à l'occasion de la sortie de mon livre
et on m'a demandé on m'a dit ce serait
bien de mettre quelqu'un un peu de
points de vue opposés alors ils ont
quelques personnes ont été évacuées on
avait pensé à villa ni le tournage a eu
lieu mardi prochain monsieur vite a dit
ce monsieur est au vatican la semaine
prochaine tant mieux pour lui donc on a
envisagé de m'opposer à yann le 15 c'est
ce qu'il a répondu mais ça je le dis ça
je lui dis j'ai reçu le sms le plus
dingue que j'ai reçu une peine quelques
années donc la programmatrice de
l'émission l'émission sur paris première
peut-être qu'on va commencer à
comprendre qui est qui et une nouvelle
émission
voilà ça attise de quelqu'un qui était
voilà un auteur c'est que j'ai pas les
congeler correspondance mais je vais
jouer je vais revenir sur le la médecine
c'est une parenthèse et au match aller
le sms je voulais j'ai des preuves on
m'avait dit il ya le cas ne veux pas
parce qu'il ne fait pas de politique
c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire une
des personnes et parmi tant d'autres
tous ces ingénieurs payé par le mot a
fait odéon monde de l'industrie 1
c'est-à-dire il ya de très gros
émoluments de la part de facebook tant
mieux mais je me suis a perdu toute
distance critique toute capacité
critique totalement soumis aux intérêts
mais dieu pour les virements
d'économique donc ces personnes
qui ont un pouvoir et ça tombe bien il
devait arriver voilà qui a un pouvoir
politique toutes ces personnes qui ont
un pouvoir politique puisqu'il développe
des productions qui interfère sur le
cours de nos existences qui donc donkey
petit modifie qui interfèrent dons
qu'ils ont c'est exactement ce qui est
nommé politique c'est-à-dire qu'ils
modifient et qui contribuent à définir
le cadre de l'organisation des affaires
communes ils nous répondent et répond à
cette personne je ne veux pas dialoguer
avec un ex à d'un parce que je ne fais
pas de politique
vous rendez vous compte la démission de
la responsabilité la démission de la
responsabilisation de l'ingénieur en se
lavant les mains en disant moi je suis
que dans ma bulle technique est
totalement indifférent à l'impact ddd
des conséquences et quand il s'en soucie
et quand ils vont un peu il va évoquer
l'impact des conséquences il nous dit
c'est formidable cette extraordinaire et
c'est cela c'est précisément cette
déresponsabilisation laquelle je me pose
alors je reviens à l'exemple dont l'état
exemple la médecine donc que monsieur
lequin qu'il y connaît rien qui est donc
je le redis chef du labo il ya facebook
donc qui nous raconte monsieur le quincy
vont me regarder racontez nous ce que
vous vos recherches que vous faites
auprès de facebook on comprendrait bien
ce qui se passe de vouloir continuer à
interpréter nos comportements avec oculi
cela la réalité augmentée l'informatique
émotionnel de façon à ne pas nous lâcher
la grappe continuellement de
continuellement nous suivre et vous le
système d'intelligence artificielle nous
disent continuellement prenez tel
produit plutôt que tel produit et vend
une interprétation et monétiser
l'interprétation des comportements par
en s'érigeant vous sauver la vie pour ne
sauver la vie facebook entend plate
forme et devant toutes ces informations
toutes les compagnies du monde entier ça
vous ne racontez pas et en plus vous
avez l'outrecuidance de raconter je
regarde la caméra là de nous raconter
que vous ne faites pas de politique mais
c'est honte à vous honte à vous honte je
je je pourrais faire référence à
d'autres ingénieur programmeur le grand
alexandre grothendieck mathématicien ça
c'est une parenthèse intéressante on va
revenir à la médecine alexandre retient
diack médaille fields comme villa ni à
mes grandes chaînes dire quand il avait
appris que ça de l'université de sophia
antipolis pour les recherches qui me
laissèrent des plus grands
mathématiciens du 20e siècle alexandre
votre cagnotte quand il avait appris que
pour ses recherches la recherche de son
laboratoire
bénéficier de fonds de l'otan via le
mystère de la défense qu'est ce qu'il a
fait qu'est-ce qu'il a fait alexandre e
tienne il est allé voir les responsables
de l'université il est dit moi je ne
veux pas je m'oppose à ce que mes
recherches et toute mon équipe toute
intelligence que nous mettons tout
l'invention que nous mettons toute
l'énergie que mettons tout la sueur que
nous mettons elles soient elles soient
elles se développent toutes ces forces
là toute cette inventivité là en vue de
satisfaire des intérêts est déterminée
par le mystère la défense et le et
l'otan quel café l'université
lui le dit monsieur retient dieccte le
savons vous êtes médaillé fields nous ne
pouvons malheureusement pas répondre à
votre requête
et à la requête de ceux des ingénieurs
et des scientifiques de votre
laboratoire
café gros tiac il gagnait très bien sa
vie ne gagnais bien celui dans un grand
laboratoire public il a dit je pars non
seulement il est parti quel formidable
esprit critique elle grands
mathématiciens
quel formidable
personne qui savait qu'en faisant ses
recherches là il faisait de la politique
qu'ils aient pas comme et qui n'aurait
jamais dit qu'en mayenne le cas je ne
fête pas politique en développant mes
recherches qu'at-il fait non seulement
il a démissionné
entendez bien ce que je veux dire et il
a monté une revue extraordinaire qui
s'appelle survie qui s'appelait survivre
et vivre qui rassemblait des chercheurs
des techniciens qui développer un esprit
critique par rapport à tous les
développements technologiques étaient à
l'oeuvre au cours des années 70 mon
éditeur l'échappée a publié un
formidable une formidable auto logis de
tous les textes critiques publiées par
cette revue et c'est le médaillé
alexandre vauthier niek médaillé fields
quarante ans plus tard cédric villani
médaillé fields qui est totalement à ce
sujet de 6 au monde économique au monde
politique puisque ce monsieur est député
de la majorité présidentielle la
république en marche et qui ne vise qui
est totalement soumis aux dogmes techno
libérale qui veut que l'horizon
économique et social inéluctable est
bien heureux de notre temps c'est les
développements d'intelligence
artificielle son rapport cette abjection
de son rapport qu'il a rendu à emmanuel
macron et à edouard philippe il ya six
mois qui disait qu'il fallait encore
plus investir il fallait encore plus
mobilisé tous les affaires tous les
allées des ingénieurs du monde entier en
vue d'instaurer cette pression sur la
décision en vue d'instaurer plus que
jamais ce que fait il ya le cas auprès
de facebook l'interprétation continuer
nos comportements en vue en vue
d'instituer la danoise la data driven de
manufacture l'encadrement et et
transformer le personnel à leurs dépens
des robots de chair et de sang
mais quelle quelqu'un lequel j'ai
discussions quand même que ça s'impose
j'étais sans ça fasse l'objet de
davantage difficulté les postures
chrétien il fait peut-être aussi pour
résister à la chine aux états unis à la
russie et nous un cap dans un contexte
de guerre économique
pour vous c'est une bière économique
mais c'est une guerre économique mais à
laquelle donc qu'ils aient commence à
être leaders comme n'arrête pas de
ressasser chine laurent alexandre la
chine mais regardez ce que fait la chine
mes chers amis avec une intelligence
artificielle j'ai écrit un chapitre
satellite
à huy extraordinaire alors ça va venir
que nous promet le l'intelligence
artificielle le crédit social
c'est-à-dire cette grande société de la
balance de la dénonciation de
l'évaluation des comportements dans
toute la société c'est à dire vous
traversez ma la rue il ya des systèmes
qui analysent veulent que le fait que
vous avez traversé la rue ou au mauvais
moment ça vous handicape sur
l'accès à des soins ça vous handicape de
la cgad presse à vous indique à voyager
à du travail ça va oser handicap
l'accès à la santé s'adresse un peu les
chinois c'est cette année c'est à un
encadrement
comme jamais il ya eu dans l'histoire
des conduites
palliatifs éducatif oui non mais là les
lire au lit il faut arrêter la leur et
dernier à ce point donc quand on lui dit
on est en retard que il ya des pies la
chine et les états unis qui sont
continuellement j'entends ce leur
élection des champions du monde tout nu
dire ça d'ailleurs j'ai il pèse 100
millions d'euros ouais j'ai vu j'ai fait
un entretien hier avec la tribune
journal économique un qui va paraître la
semaine prochaine dont j'ai appris qu'il
était optionnelle me l'ont dit là bas
ils m'ont montré à la cause de son
prochain j'ai envie d'y regoûter ainsi
jma pas des bouquins ce qu'il écrit
c'est bon avec ça s'appelle les
politiques et l'ia qui fait avec jean
françois copé mais valls à mettre un lit
où ils vont continuer de dire tu es
politiques ne comprennent rien qu'il
faut investir davantage bien donc c'est
la démission de tout esprit critique
la démission de toute
velléité à voir ce qui se joue au profit
du du primat économique et avec tout le
nid tendue des incidences
civilisationnel que je suis allé voir de
près et qui m'offusque alors je reviens
vous êtes d'accord que je reviens sur
les avantages on en est on encore une
heure et demie selon va dire on a même
toute la nuit à ce rythme là je veux
j'étais venu un peu fatigué mais là ça y
est vous m'avez réveillé avec vos
question ironique ou vos remarques
ironiques lesparre fait à dessein alors
la médecine voilà un très bon exemple
aussi bien de fonctionnalités de ce que
permettent les systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle mais aussi d'une
chronologie fame expliqué pascal assez
compliqué ce que j ai pu l'expliquer on
va très bien comprendre
l'intelligence artificielle
des systèmes
d'interprétation de certains secteurs
professionnels
on sait qu ibm a fait ça depuis quelques
années enfin depuis le début des années
2010 et notamment son système le plus
connu c'est watson tout le monde connaît
watson
qui a été à l'origine un système de
formidables vous m'entendez jeudi
formidable la terrifiant non ci devient
mise au pas du tout formés au sein d'un
terrifiant bon mais alors là moi je me
dis tu es un point de vue naïf et
candide formidable c'est un organe
de collecte d'informations
de toutes sortes relative les
informations à des foyers de pathologies
dans le monde entier à
des effets secondaires de molécules sur
des patients relatives à des des
traitements de
de pathologie de cancer ou autres
pathologies graves
individualisé avec les résultats les
suivi
relatif des foyers d'infection donc
c'est un formidable instrument
d'information al usage du corps médical
donc par exemple pour des molécules
d'avoir une avancée plus vidal vous
connaissez le vidal le diction ça donne
des informations relativement des effets
secondaires très récent sur quel type de
personne ni de l'argent à la sécu on
peut dire ça comme ça où ça permet de
dessiner l'appréciation de certains cas
dans la médecine mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut comment il faut comprendre cette
première fonctionnalité qui était la
première des quads sonne là on est loin
des discours expéditif je suis dans
l'analyse de près de ce qui se passe à
st après on va voir comment il ya des
échelons parce que là encore je les fais
dans mon livre avec la médecine j'ai
écrit un chapitre qui s'appelle la
médecine au crac mis sous le joug du
privé dont on me dit la médecine c'est
formidable je suis allé voir donc là
puisque nous parlons de deux
fonctionnalités formidable comme ce que
tu viens de dire mais la moelle pas du
tout ironique réel donc là il ya un
instrument d'information d'accès à
l'information mais je le redis je le
redis c'est cela ce seuil ce point qu'on
ne voit pas suffisamment qui permet au
corps médical en théorie de faire ce
qu'il veut ce corps médical le médecin
envoyant des informations de faire ce
qu'il veut depuis quelques temps donc là
je parle de ces fonctionnalités qui
continue de se développer ce que je n'ai
pas dit c'est que ce système watson
analyser aussi
synthétiser analyse elysées entre
guillemets parce que les systèmes mise
aujourd'hui par lise c'est le devenir
anthropomorphique de la technique c'est
comme ça il faut bien qu'on en paye les
conséquences aussi de celui
anthropomorphique peut-être qu'on n'a
pas le temps mais bon donc liste des
articles et synthétise d'essence article
scientifique donc avec des mots clés
quel médecin peut lire des milliers
d'articles scientifiques n'ont pas le
temps donc les synthétise donc on voit
bien que c'est un instrument de dax est
extrêmement rationaliser aisé à
l'information ça c'était 2011-2012-2013
2004 et ça a continué de se développer
parallèlement s'est développée une autre
fonctionnalité
dont on ne cesse de parler vous l'avez
peut-être entendu dont on essaye débat
c'est là le diagnostic automatisés alors
là c'est la panique annoncés l'ofs
l'enthousiasmé planétaire inde et que je
dis deschamps dit mais tu as vu le
métier dès que je développe des points
de vue critiques on me dit mais ce que
tu vois la médecine juifs seulement la
médecine diagnostic automatiser la voilà
cette extraordinaire alors
certes depuis deux ans il ya des cas de
deux pathologies comment sur l'odeur
d'anthologie en dermatologie radiologie
des dégâts moustiques automatisé alors
je vais dire quelques petites choses à
prévoir le troisième échelon la
troisième fonctionnalités ça c'est la
deuxième fonctionnalité la cette
fonctionnalité déjà déjà déjà
elle est appelée n'est ce pas n'est ce
pas on en a parlé tout à l'heure avec le
machine learning avec de plus en plus
fiables à se sophistiquer sans cesse je
fais une parenthèse de taille nous avons
parlé j'ai parlé du fait que nous
entrons c'est pas nouveau mais c'est
plus que jamais nous entrons dans une
société extrêmement utilitariste donc
c'est une jeune personne le gan le cas
et tant d'autres elle est une des
magazines qui avantagent la médecine
c'est extraordinaire ça ne gêne personne
que la figure du médecin que tu une
personne important dans la société un
cas qui a requis de longues études qui a
qui a une connaissance évolutive des
patients qui a une expérience planté qui
peut se planter alors je vais t'en dire
quelques mots d'abord sur ce fameux qui
peut se planter un
sans gêne personne et cette figure alors
un qui tue une figure un peu structurant
de la société et des relations humaines
c'est à dire c'est le soin le soin ça
gêne personne que par pertes et profits
à terme on met sur la touche au profit
de l'expertisé automatisé qui est appelé
à être sans cesse se sophistiquer c'est
une parenthèse moi ça me gêne en tant
qu'être humain et en tant que citoyen
que des compétences aussi
convaincu temps d'un conte requis tant
d'années et qui ont tant d'expérience
qui qui appelle aussi la relation human
vont être à terme talent expertise sans
cesse sophistiqué par la machine
learning car aujourd'hui nous sommes en
2018 que vont être ses systèmes en 2030
c'est à l'europe nous faut être plus on
argue parce qu'il faut bien faire avaler
la pilule un atout ce bon peuple un des
développements on argue de la
complémentarité homme machine oui
peut-être en 2018 en 2025 racontez-moi
la complémentarité homme machine alors
maintenant je veux dire bédié encore
autre chose avec ces systèmes de
diagnostic dont on va affecter une aura
de plus en plus indéniable il serait bon
que dans les hôpitaux
que quand lorsqu'un système de
diagnostic automatisé établi une
pathologie grave et des systèmes de
contrôle linguistique ou de m'utiliser
ça personne n'en parle ça coûte très
cher déjà un système de diagnostic ou de
monétiser coûte très très cher allez
demander à un hôpital de faire un
système de contrats diagnostic donc là
il va y avoir des problèmes de fiabilité
d'orage supposé au système et je fais
encore une petite parenthèse qui n'en
est pas une on fait comme si les
médecins n'arrêtait pas de se planter
continuellement
mais vous savez des erreurs de
diagnostic
il y en a irna c'est malheureux mais
c'est extrêmement dérisoire parce que
quand il ya une pathologie grave qui est
détectée dans les hôpitaux qu'est-ce qui
se passe il ya du contre diagnostic il
ya des médecins qui se réunissent dans
les hôpitaux publics c'est ce qui se
passe et c'est d'évaluer à plusieurs
donc on arrête de nous raconter que les
médecins n'arrête pas de faire des
bêtises il ya une expertise médicale
notamment sur les pathologies graves qui
existent mais pourquoi y at il cette
passion du diagnostic automatisés alors
comme disait la marionnette de sarkozy
moi je vais vous le dire pourquoi il ya
ces systèmes de diagnostic automatisé
qui sont développés moi je vais vous le
dire comme dylan comme disait la
marionnette parce que ces mêmes systèmes
qui sont pas du tout développés par le
corps médical ils sont développées par
les sciences non ils sont développées
par l'industrie de la 2d et du numérique
ont vu de quoi là il faut être faut me
suivre chers amis la formule suivre
point par point là je vous accompagne
avec moi de faire un point qu'il faut
comprendre il faut me suivre en vue de
quoi en vue de faire sauter le monde
médical ce qui est nommé en médecine le
paiement à l'acte au profit d'une
logique d'abonnement qui vient des
capteurs que nous sommes amenés à porter
interprète
collecte en temps réel les flux
physiologique et des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle
interprète en temps réel les états de
chacun à terme à l'échelle de la planète
et ses grandes industries de la donner
et des plateformes et de et des
numériques et aussi des plateformes
entend diriger alors c'est compliqué
mais je veux dire simplement les chaudes
eux mêmes
des
officines médicale alors que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre google c'était la requête
de mots clés les plateforme éducative
non maintenant et apple et tous ces
grands groupes de l'industrie veut se
positionner sur le champ de la santé car
on imagine toi l'échelle de la planète
les chiffres d'affaires que ça
représente et entendent s'ériger jeudi
précisément en tant que
plate-forme entre l'industrie
pharmaceutique ou est même montée des
cabinets médicaux ce qui existe déjà
dans le monde car ces systèmes de
diagnostic automatisés mais c'est aussi
à l'oeuvre avec l'interprétation en
temps réel des flux physiologique et ses
systèmes de diagnostic automatisé et
cela il faut l'entendre quand on parle
des avantages de la médecine il faut
entendre les contre les conséquences
collatérales et c'est quoi les
conséquences collatérales c'est une
gigantesque entreprise de privatisation
de la médecine de confiscation du champ
de la santé par les grandes entreprises
de l'industrie du numérique c'est même
système de diagnostic au dos métier ce
qu'on ne dit jamais et là je m'énerve je
vénère pour la bonne cause car j'en ai
marre d'entendre dire que voilà un
terrain un domaine où on va tous
bénéficié celui de la médecine ces mêmes
systèmes de diagnostic entendez bien ce
que je veux dire c'est déjà le cas aux
etats-unis sont des systèmes de
prescription automatisés c'est à dire
que ces systèmes qui sont fabriqués
élaboré conçu par le monde économie par
le monde industriel
vont eux mêmes par l'achat de mots clés
c'est
le computationnelle on voit pas c'est
pas la théorie du complot qui dit qu'il
a vu une masse de données c'est ce sont
des millions de lignes de code qui
moulinent en permanence il va y avoir il
y à de l'achat de mots clés et donc
l'intégrité du médecin qu'on met comme
ça sur le bas côté au nom d'utilitarisme
et du diagnostic automatisé à
l'intégrité je le veux bien supposée du
médecin est appelé à être évacué au
profit de grands groupes de l'industrie
de données qui diagnostique les
pathologies ou qui interprète en temps
réel nos états physiologiques et qui
s'érige en tant que plateforme où elle
même propose des visites par des
logiques d'abonnement nous allons faire
de l'abonnement la fin de la médecine du
paiement à l'acte 1 et qui s'érige en
tant que plate-forme entre le monde
pharmaceutique est pas le monde médical
et entre chacun d'entre nous alors est
ce que c'est la compétence de
l'industrie numérique de ces régions en
tant que plate forme entre les passions
les individus citoyens patients et le
monde pharmaceutique donc l'intelligence
artificielle dans la médecine au nom du
diagnostic surpuissant automatisés comme
s'il y avait des dires de diagnostic
continuellement nous ne voyons pas et je
crois que je suis le seul à dire je peux
dire en toute modestie que je suis le
seul aujourd'hui sur notre petite
planète a dit et je suis interpellé moi
faut le dire par des collectifs de
médecins j'ai un mal là je pourrai vous
le ressortir monsieur marty une
association française pour une médecine
libre qui m'a qui m'interpellait qui me
mavita à l'est devenu un congrès de
médecins ils vont un peu gueulé sur ce
qui se passe actuellement un voit-on la
gigantesque
entreprise de
marchandisation de privatisation de la
santé et ils font avaler passer des
lanternes pour commander c'est quoi les
pressions pas céder l'un des vessies
pour des lanternes
avec cette fable des sempiternel
avantages ou des supposés avantages du
diagnostic automatisés sao fut-sp ça
occulte pardon toute cette entreprise
qu'on ne voit pas mais qui est à
l'oeuvre car ce qui est à l'oeuvre c'est
les capteurs c'est le suivi pas
seulement il interrompu de nos gestes
commerciaux de l'état dans notre
baignoire de notre le sommeil de c1
continuent de nos flux physiologique et
alors là c'est bingo c'est toute
l'industrie de bien-être c'est ça en
plus ça instaure une autre tranche de
pénétration nos comportements c'est un
des capteurs des plus physiologique qui
peuvent aussi être utilisées à des fins
commerciales pas que médicales si je
sais que vous tous et en pleine nuit je
peux vous proposer je peux vous mettre
en relation mots clés avec je sais pas
des pulls d'amaru uniqlo qui est qui
chauffe en hiver et états unis on peut
diagnostiquer la mort précoce du
nourrisson a réinvité la mort précoce du
nourrisson ou des choses comme ça oui
mais
ce qu'il faut saisir ces discrétion
avantages inconvénients il faut il faut
la mettre de côté
c'est ça que moi j'aime et je vais le
faire à dire ça un couple qui a perdu
son avenir mais je ce que je m'efforce
de faire c'est de mettre cette
sempiternelle équation qui ne faire qui
me fait rien avancer et qui occulte des
shows allons voir ce qui se passe de
majo ce que je nomme majorité est ce
qu'on est capable d'analyser ce qui se
passe de majoritairement structures là
dans la médecine on va me dire au nom
d'un cas de dire ça mais attend il ya
plein de médecins qui sont capables de
diagnostiquer des risques possibles
écoutez faut arrêter avec cette fable de
la surpuissance du dainik automatisé qui
dit une chose cela qui dit quoi qui dit
la puissance de fascination et doha tu
comprends doha au sens de pratiques d
apostrophes a eu r à
canaliser benyamine water benyamine en
son époque laura laura qu'on accorde à
ces systèmes mais comme si l'humain
n'arrêtait pas de faire connerie sur
connerie et notamment les médecins il y
en a qui en font mais arrêtons de croire
que le que les le diagnostic médical
était un champ de ruines ce n'est pas du
tout le cas ça coûte cher la médecine
c'est peut-être le seul hic ou alors
certainement pas car c'est là il ya des
investissements il y à des
investissements qui sont dont les
médecins m'ont interpellé pour me
raconter cela tient la ddt aujourd'hui
il faut qu'ils aient transformation
digitale de tout un alors voilà une
expression forges et par les
évangélistes de l'industrie du numérique
et impôts ces discours transformation
mesdames et messieurs du lycée alors la
ministre de de l'éducation de hollande a
fait entrer grandes portes ouvertes dans
l'éducation contrats signés en 2015
comme elle s'appelait najat vallaud
voilà qui signe un grand contrat avec le
microsoft entrait microsoft car aucun
compétence éducation nationale
transformation digitale de l'école
publique entraîne très
évidemment c'est le résultat du lobbying
donc aujourd'hui les évangélistes de la
numérisation intégrale du monde nous
disent qu'il faut que tout il ya la
transformation digitale de tous
notamment de l'entreprise on a vu que on
a un peu parlé de certaines conséquences
collatérales
des médecins maternal en dix ans et eux
mêmes enfin un nombre malheureusement
minoritaires disent maintenant ces
évangélistes là ils ont réussi à imposer
la doxa de la transformation digitale de
la médecine c'est une catastrophe c'est
à dire que ce sont ces comme pour
l'école qui hollande avait dit en
novembre 2014 pourquoi je me souviens
des dates d'abord parce que j'ai une
passion des dates mais parce que quand
je l'avais entendu parler de ça j'ai
aussitôt dégainé une tribune qui est
parue dans libération une semaine plus
tard où il avait dit en 2014 ça c'est
pas du tout passé comme ça mais là c'est
le résultat du lobbying de la
transformation digitale de tous sains et
notamment de l'éducation et de la
médecine on va reparler il avait dédié à
partir de la rentrée 2015 tous les
collégiens vont avoir des tablettes
numériques
alors moi j'avais deux ponts d'une
tribune qui était en ligne pour ceux que
ça intéresse sur libération qui sont
vendus dans la foulée sur amazon voilà
et que j'avais nommé intitulé libé à
l'égard d'haïti c'était très bien
l'ineptie des tablettes numériques à
l'école et après il se trouve très
intéressant j'avais été donné des
conférences dans quelques conseils
généraux qui est donc comme tu le sais
s'occupe des ont la compétence des
collages et m'ont dit que sa voile sont
ses tablettes on a dépensé un freak
dingue elles sont toutes dans les sous
sols les profs n'ont pas été fermées ça
s'est fait dans la plus grande le terme
que je vais dire car c'est à tout elle
même en scène dans la plus grande
précipitation sans que des études
d'impact 100 kg et
l'implication des professeurs des
parents d'élèves de voir comment cela se
passerait le fait du prince hollande dit
il va y avoir des tablettes avec une
catastrophe heureusement que ce n'est
pas le cas alors maintenant le fait du
prince ou le fait de la doxa ou le fait
du lobbying car on n'a pas le passé de
faim il ya lobbying de l'industrie
numérique mais qui est d'une puissance
qui d'une puissance qui forgent les
représentations et qui est et qui impose
la doxa que selon laquelle si tout doit
aller mieux dans tous les secteurs de la
société il faut que ça passe par des
investissements dans des systèmes
investissements dans la digitalisation
de tous avec des sens que ça ça ne fait
l'appel de l'examen critique de la part
de toutes les personnes concernées sans
que ça fasse
l'examen de d'étude d'impact sur des
effets de laboratoire c'est à dire sur
des cas de figure restreint on
expérimente quand même les choses car le
lobbing c'est une des premières
puissances hockey auquel succombent le
monde politique mais aussi ensuite la
société toute entière qui impose la doxa
de l'inéluctable l'inéluctable c'est
c'est l'autre nom de l'une et l'autre
non des lignes luc table c'est le fait
de dessaisir la société de son droit à
décider librement du cours de nos
destins collectifs comme un lieu de
l'inéluctable ses clous et le clouer le
bec à nos droits de parole
l'exponentielle les technologies de l'
exponentielle parce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans le temps d'expérience
yalin les technologies de l'
exponentielle car nous vivons un miracle
aujourd'hui à l'humain écoles pétri de
défaut le monde est chaotique mais nous
vivons un miracle nous disent les grands
gourous de l'industrie du numérique mais
aussi toute cette doxa les
technologiques exponentielle vont
racheter tous les défauts de la terre à
vitesse exponentielle
donc je reviens à mon affaire de
transformation digitale
des hôpitaux de la médecine qui suppose
de la mobilisation de l'investissement
d'argent public et là je lui dis
j'interpelle les citoyens puisque des
médecins m'ont parlé de ça ça te pose
soit par l'impôt et bien sûr que
generali keitel sa musique mais je
connais ça par coeur mais là on parle
pas de médecine on parle d'autre chose
n'aura ni qu'on va en dire quelques mots
aussi si tu le souhaites mais des
médecins me disent mais c'est incroyable
ces investissements qui s'opèrent sur le
fait de deux de
généraliser l'usagé de systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle sans du tout
que ça fasse l'objet de débats sans voir
l'impact s'en
saisir comme ferez quoi tu ferais quoi
site était aux manettes eh bien je sais
je d'abord je ne veux pas être aux
manettes et ensuite pour ma part tu sais
le dernier livre chapitre de mon livre
s'appelait intitulé manifeste de
l'action tient on y vient autant d
l'exponentielle
je ne suis pas aux manettes je ne veux
pas être aux manettes en revanche
j'appelle à une chose
puisque il y à une telle puissance
technique aux industriels puisque il ya
une telle soumission du monde politique
puisqu'il ya une telle soumission c'est
la même chose que législateur et bien
que nous reste-t-il à instaurer ce
modèle de société je le redis bien
fondés sur l'interprétation en temps
réel de tous nos comportements et leurs
orientations le guidage de l'action
humaine à des fins en vue de répondre à
dessein des intérêts privés ou en vue
d'aller vers le crédit social c'est à
dire l'organisation
hyper
rationaliser
et évacuant tout défaut
de la société puisqu'il y a une telle
puissance une telle démission du
politique du législateur puisqu'il faut
arrêter de croire à cette fable de la
régulation et à cette frappe de da
surcroît d'éthique sai l'éthique c'est
comme l'appliqué on va mettre un peu
d'éthique à la bête puisse tout va aller
mieux 1 comme le range de vilain ce qui
développe des robots empathique dire
cette abjection la des robots qui
interprète nos émotions et qui vont nous
assister mais mes métis à la poubelle
cette horreur la développer d'autres
techniques deux techniques d'autres
modalités techniques fondées sur une
autre vision de l'existence donc à
l'écart de tous ces discours nous dit
oui ce qu'il faut faire c'est mettre un
peu d'éthique j'ai dit tout à l'heure
toute cette fable rhin eh bien je crois
que c'est plus que jamais à nous à qui
il revient oui de faire oeuvre de
politiques c'est à dire de nous saisir à
toutes les échelles de la société et de
sous quelle forme déjà avons nous le
droit de ne pas être béat ou d'être
passé et de dire là où il ya des
systèmes qui bafouent notre intégrité et
notre dignité on le refuse
dans le monde de l'entreprise
ces systèmes qui voit des signaux énoncé
via des casques audio à du personnel les
actions à entreprendre il s'agirait il
serait temps que les syndicats ne se
soucie pas et c'est important que des
niveaux de salaire mais s'oppose à ces
objections 1 on peut quand même non
ab non bien sûr que non et puis
s'agirait aussi parce que j'ai réfléchir
des modalités d'action les gens qui ont
un casque qui portent des couches pour
travailler mais parce ya cela mais aussi
où les bottes de management aujourd'hui
c'est de là on en a parlé sont des
systèmes qui qui portent des intérêts
qui pas des modes d'action ne perds pas
ton fils un bon je parle je perds pas
mon fils de gêne on sait j'ai essayé
j'ai travaillé sur ce nom précisément
sur des modes d'action possible moi je
veux pas être aux manettes que puisque
tu poses la question de façon
extrêmement catégorique en revanche je
veux travailler à la l'éveil de
conscience et à la possibilité de ne
rentrer agissant voilà on touche un
point extraordinaire l'éveil des
consciences oui
raconte moi un petit peu comment tu fais
pour éveiller des gens qui ont la tête
dans le guidon qui savent à peine
utilisé un téléphone portable qui ont
des problèmes de boulot de pognon de
santé qui sont dans un stress dans une
catatonique émotionnel et dans un
égoïsme pure et simple qui sont poussés
dans une société qui veut de plus en
plus vite qui demandent plus en plus de
performances je t'en fais donc
l'élément catalyseur ou l'élément
exotiques ou cette prise de conscience
c'était veille ouvrir les yeux de ça
comme tu veux raconte moi tu vas faire
ça comment
d'abord tu as catch du cran patc de
scouts a beaucoup parlé écrit là tu
comprends pas que tu planes est un peu
là si dans les gens ils n'iraient pas
modificés le 17 pour le prix du gasoil
surtout que c'est surtout ça c'est pas
pour l'écologie qui se sait ce que
l'état monte de pognon ils se font taxer
ouah ça passe avec pour des questions
d'écologie là il ya une énorme
manifestation qui entendent se préparer
pour bloquer le pays mais simplement
parce que ça touche un peu le
portefeuille
du reste donc tu vas les éveillés comme
aux masses informes je chante en
consigne qui met plein temps via sa
forme complètement décérébrés égoïste
qui n'est pas le cas il entend dire
pourquoi j'entends que j'entends bien
dans ta question le présupposé le
présupposé c'est que
nous sommes autant la démission c'est à
dire puisque les choses sont en cours
puisque la puissance et du côté du mont
technico industrials arrête avec tes
discours critique arrête avec tes appels
à la mobilisation la mobilisation car
pour l'écologie j'en appelle à la
conscience arrête ses vins alors tu sais
à quoi est-ce que je te réponds à cela
je te réponds je suis pas dupe je suis
pas naïve du tout je sais bien que la
marche
d'être actif relativement à ces
puissances lors assez puissant cela
allait très mince mais elle existe et si
on n'essayait pas de de l'exploiter ce
goût d'être agissant mais c'est la
vérité je vais dire des choses si on
essayait pas d'être agissant tel des
missions qu'elle démission à laquelle je
ne me résous pas alors qu'est ce que
c'est être agissant à mon sens déjà nous
avons parlé des évangélistes des
discours déjà je crois qu contre les
experts patentés qui disent qu'ils nenê
cesse des véhicules et des discours qui
sont portés qui répondent à des intérêts
un faisons valoir des contres discours
mais faisons valoir enfin des contres
discours qui émane de la réalité du
terrain ces médecins qui m'interpelle je
les engage les appels à prendre
davantage la parole tokyo villani qui
vient de pondre un livre sur avec un
médecin je crois un médecin ou quelqu'un
qui est dans l'industrie2 je sais pas
trop quoi il faut vérifier à dire c'est
formidable ce qu'il fasse avec la
médecine député la france en marche tous
qu'il va voter des lois pour que des
médecins prennent la parole et nous dit
c'est pas les choux les choses se
passent pas comme villani nous le
raconte et comme l'industrie du
numérique nous le raconte faisons valoir
des contres témoignages des
contre-expertises dans l'entreprise que
les syndicats et les personnes qui
subissent ces objections des systèmes
qui orientent l'action humaine nous
raconte enfin se remonter les contre
expertises
à l'opposé de toute cette dockside de
ces discussions des discours formatés je
continue
à dérouler la réponse à ta question je
crois que malheureusement
pas joli nid nous avons perdu la faculté
à dire non
relativement à
certains dispositifs qui sont qui
s'imposent à nos existences sans faire
appel à notre assentiment
enfin non pas la guerre
des dispositifs qui bafouent notre
dignité notre intégrité humaine j'en ai
parlé dans l'entreprise j'en ai parlé
dans le recrutement aujourd'hui des des
jeunes étudiants déjà recruté par des
systèmes en vue de critères bon il ya la
liste est très longue j'annonce dans le
livre avons-nous le de trouver un livre
avons nous le droit
de nous avons nous
l'énergie
le courage
l'impulsion de dire cela on n'en veut
pas c'est tout le contraire qui se passe
au nom des discours au nom de la
banalisation au nom du discours de
l'inéluctable il ya des formes d'apathie
tu as raison il ya des formes d'apathie
il ya des formes de naturalisation ces
développements alors mis à l'orge si on
n'est pas critique si on n'est pas un
laissez-passer pour ce pas de signaler
ce qui se joue entre dans une démission
généralisée je lui dis à laquelle je ne
me résous pas mais aussi autre chose et
aussi autre chose parce que là il s'agit
de me le dire non mais ça je vais te le
dire comme dirait l'autre là il s'agit
de vents contraires mais il s'agirait
aussi de faire valoir d'autres
imaginaires proposer d'autres sud mais
exergue évidemment mais d'autres est
imaginaire c'est à dire une autre vision
la société propose ce coin mais que ce
que cet utilitarisme je propose enfin je
propose n'est-il pas possible
déjà
puisque nous parlons de techniques des
techniques aux économies et que
l'imaginaire technique a été totalement
enrégimentés par le monde économique
n'y at il pas d'autres
modal techniques d'autres trajectoires
technique ad levé la main sur le coeur
quand tu dis ça mais je le crois mais
pourquoi pourquoi se trouve ironique
parce que tu t'es possédé par ce que tu
dis je me sens très très bonne et je le
crois plus que jamais un peu utopiste
non mais c'est pas utopiste je vais
quand même vous raconter une anecdote
puisque je balance un peu ce soir elle
est conne et vilaine il est les deux
leaders les alex heures ils en prennent
pour leur grade et pas suffisamment il
c'est que le début un c'est que le début
vont en prendre de plus en plus un il ya
quand même une école d'ingénieurs
malheureusement j'oublie son nom à
chaque fois je vais vous le retrouvez
m'avait invitée au moment là il ya deux
ans la sécurisation du monde a donné une
conférence auprès de leurs jeunes
étudiants ingénieurs de l'école de lyon
de codeurs d'ingénieurs tout avait été
calé le bon de commande la date les
billets de train on avait même préparé
ce que ce que je sais que je comptais
dire voilà le plan de la conférence que
je n'étais totalement libre et ils
m'appellent pour dire l'état des choses
il m'appelle une semaine avant et ils me
disent monsieur sadin
cécile était pris panique on va devoir
annuler votre invitation
jeu du pardon oui parce qu'on a lu dans
l'entretien que j'avais donnée à
libération que vous opposiez au compteur
linky si oui alors le dit écoutez et les
dix donc
l'opérateur est un de nos sponsors
principaux de notre école donc on a la
trouille en fait un alors moi je dis
alors moi je vous ai dit écoutez madame
madame deux heures de parole critique
dans l'année deux heures qui aurait pu
faire l'objet de débats à la fin au
cours de ma présentation je m'en fiche
c'est trop c'est trop
c'est à dire qu invité une parole
critique dans votre école c'est trop et
que ce qui compte c'est la soumission à
votre sponsor qui détermine consciemment
et inconsciemment les programmes à lyon
vous invitera
plus tard j'ai écouté madame ou de ma
vie serait plus jamais je viendrai
jamais honte à vous je vais d'ailleurs
écrit une tribune dans le monde pour
dénoncer ce que vous ce qui se passe là
un pour rendre visible alors ils ont été
pris de panique ils m'ont écrit 50 mail
jamais répondu aucun jeu n'est pas très
de cette tribune ne jouerait plus la
peur c'est pour dire comment par exemple
quand je parle de pluralité de la
recherche pluralité de trajectoire
techniques possibles les monde de
l'enseignement
le monde des écoles d'ingénieurs le
monde de l'université et le terme il est
un peu péjoratif mais c'est le cas il
est infiltré par les grandes entreprises
regardez paristech j'ai encore lu une
tribune enfin dans le monde et qu e les
pages éco très intéressant.moi jolie
page des coups du monde tous les jours
un aussi du figaro et mais aussi des
échos julie sahin des gens de paris
taille qu'un donc il ya le regroupement
de plein d'université un sacré et c'est
tout le monde sait ça pareil on est en
retard
écosystème que cette métaphore
biologique ne nous on la recherchait pas
un écosystème le système c'est
biologique c'est pas du tout on n'est
pas dans le biologique la des affaires
humaines on est dans la contradiction ou
des intérêts divers on est dans la
pluralité humaine ya pas d'écosystème 1
c'est encore voilà un terme auquel je
m'oppose
donc paristech et voilà il faut encore
plus d'investissement toujours la même
histoire la chine et devant etc mais
toutes ces écoles elles sont infiltrées
par les grands groupes les grandes
industries et qui façonnent
détermine consciemment et inconsciemment
vous avez vu c'est peut-être qu'elle
n'existerait pas vu du à redire après
avec mon invitation à l'école
d'ingénieurs mais façonne détermine
consciemment ou inconsciemment la
structuration des études et qu'est ce
que c'est que cette structuration des
études c'est le c'est le principe qui
veut que les développements l'état de la
recherche
ce qui est supposé comme étant comme le
système économique c'est c2c de répondre
à cette trajectoire en cours essai j'ai
pas en cours je l'a redit en une seule
phrase très simplement c'est cette
abjection d'interpréter en temps réel
nos comportements continuellement en
temps réel et continuellement sait pas
même chose en temps réel jusqu'à la nuit
avec des bandeaux puisse dans le lit en
temps réel continuellement nos états en
vue de monétiser cette connaissance
continuellement et en vue d'instaurer
une organisation algorithmique police et
ultra rationaliser et génisses de la
société qui est risque d'aller à terme
sait-on jamais jusqu au crédit social
chinois n'y at il pas dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs dans les universités mais
aussi dans notre imaginaire collectif et
individuel la possibilité d'imaginer
d'autres développements techniques que
fondées sur ce strict utilitarisme et
cette capitalisation continue delà de
l'interprétation des comportements c'est
cela que je dénonce et c'est cette
structuration techno-économique que que
c'est vers cette visée que sont
conçus les les développements actuels
alors je pose une question cette fois ci
c'est moi qui te poses la question cette
fois ci c'est moi qui vous pose la
question à tous les moyens en société de
faire un écart par rapport à la
puissance techno industrielle de marquer
un pas de côté et de dire vous voulez
développer les choses comme cela nous
nous avons l'intelligence nous avons
l'inventivité nous avons envie nous
avons la foi nous avons le caprice nous
avons le le désir nous avons la folie
nous avons là envie d'imaginer les
choses autrement tu connais de tout
autrement je connais notre dame de
lourdes
exactement je crois que ce sont des add
à toutes les échelles de la société
qu'il faut inventer c'est très bien
comme quoi tu écoute ce que je dis je
bave armée dessus tout ce que je dis
c'est très bien ce que tu ta remarque
cette fois ci à des pailles ironique
aller en plein lorsque je signale je
crois que ce qui nous revient
aujourd'hui tu parais de la
manifestation du 17 novembre sur le coût
du gazole etc pour encore plus consommer
de galles je crois que ce qui nous
revient
c'est d'inventer je vous dis dans mon
livre cette phrase exactement c'est
d'inventer des années mais pas seulement
à notre dame des landes pas seulement
dans l'espace mais à toutes les échelles
de la société la voulait construire le
travail comme ça nous on construit
autrement est ce que tu as vu ce film
lui l'homme n'est une île c'est super
bien c'est un dock je crois qu'il a été
réalisé par internet marche à ce jeu est
ce que tu as vu elysées home je n'ai pas
vu parce que tu as vu bienvenue à
gattaca évidemment
ouais mais bon mais en tout cas ni
l'homme à propos de saad il ya un moment
à un ébéniste qu'à une entreprise qui
est dans une forêt un ébéniste
autrichien je crois qui est dans une
forêt qui parle très bien du cycle des
arbres comment ils font très attention à
comment les les coupés au bon moment
après des cycles santé qu'il avait une
sorte de damour d'empathie avec la forêt
pack l'empathie que les robots que les
ingénieurs qu'on développe et improvisée
de l'empathie avec nous ces robots
empathie que mettez les à la casse ça je
les détruire et bien je ferai bien une
virée pour la détruire leurs saloperies
de robots empathique une parenthèse donc
il disait cette cet ébéniste qu'à un
moment voit dans la forêt et un moment
le voit dans son entretien sont dans son
entreprise dont les voiliers travailler
avec santé qui avait le fait que
personne été lésés que tout le monde
était dans une sorte de plaisir du
travail et un moment il dit voilà des
add il disait pourtant sont entre eux
mais n'arrêtaient pas de se développer
ce qui est développé un pratiquer un
travail un très bel artisanat comme ça
existe encore aujourd'hui très cher qui
coûte très cher mais qui marche très
bien et tu sais ce qu'ils avaient dit à
un moment je n'ai pas oublié cette
parole peut-être que de moi je suis
tellement pas oublier que j'ai mis dans
mon livre parfois tu vois qu'elle foute
en tant que parent du diois faut
l'entendre cela est il dit
nous on a décidé j'ai décidé nous avons
décidé que même si nous n'arrêtons pas
nous développer nous n'irons pas au delà
10 de 10 personnes c'est magnifique
ce qu au delà il ya un seuil ça va plus
être le même esprit il y aura
définitivement des personnes qui vont
dans des jeux de pouvoir leur dominé à
vouloir exploit il n'en veut pas chacun
y trouve son compte c'est que là dans
son travail eh bien on répondra pas
toutes les commandes c'est pas grave
c'est magnifique donc c'est quand on
parle de zad d adam travail je pense
qu'on est on est totalement ces
terribles ou dans des temps d un etat de
la société ou un voile assez on est dans
la survie la survie des gens acceptent
de se dette pilotés par des systèmes de
répondre à des mais je crois que si on
veut comprendre une horreur mais je suis
pas le seul à le dire ça une horreur du
monde qu'on cap aura une des horreurs du
monde contemporain vous allez en
entreprise le monde du management s'ils
voulaient saisir aujourd'hui lac mais
parce que nous parlons d'un moment de
l'extrême rationalisation de la société
c'est une vieille histoire c'est un lieu
depuis la révolution industrielle ça a
lieu depuis
taylor depuis ford depuis le début du
20e siècle nous vivons
l'histoire du monde depuis un siècle en
occident maintenant ça regarde le monde
entier et est l'histoire d'un
accroissement continu al de la
rationalisation de la société est
aujourd'hui avec ces systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle et l'état de
la technique c'est un nouveau seuil d'un
extrême rationalisation de la société et
cette extrême rationalisation de la
société si on veut aller voir comme dans
sas comment ça se pratique comment ça
s'applique vers le monde du management
et là vous allez voir comment les
personnes non plus un souffle la
possibilité de souffler la moindre
seconde au profit de quoi je crois que
si on veut aussi comprendre ce qui se
joue avec ces systèmes c'est une notion
extrêmement importante c'est le temps
réel c'est le temps mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire le temps réel le temps réel
c'est la visibilité au moment même où
les choses se passent de l'évolution des
phénomènes et une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a pas tout dit qu'est ce que ça veut
dire aussi dire qu'il ya plus d'espacé
avec les événements on sait ce qui se
passe au moment même où ça ici ou là où
elles ont lieu et donc qu'est ce que ça
veut dire aussi c'est à dire qu'on peut
agir sur les comportements au soin des
humains soient des systèmes au moment
même où les phénomènes c'est donc vous
attend donc la pression camisole
numérique a je crois que c'est tu me la
pète pas pour ton prochain bouquin cela
mais c'est le terme est bien mais quand
on entend kamiza il faut pas que ça soit
un slogan que tu comprends il faut
comprendre comment
cette pression sur l'addition humaine a
lieu elle va avoir de plus en plus vieux
mais je vous le redis à différents
niveaux c'est pas pareil cette camisole
quand une ans est connecté me dit vous
devriez le voir tel film au vu de la
connaissance des comportements que
lorsque un système de diagnostic ou un
système de deux d'interprétation terre
en temps réel de mes flux physiologique
me dise ouhlala oulalalala vous avez mal
couru prenez tels compléments
alimentaires là j'ai des doutes je me
dis les systèmes sont tellement
puissants et aimerait tellement puissant
qu'est ce que j'aurai les moyens un
moment de dire ce complément alimentaire
si ce système il dit à une mauvaise
foulée il faudra qu'il fasse une
meilleure foulée ou où tu t'appuies plus
à droite tu vas avoir mal au dos
attention va peut-être chez toys booster
ou
la tuer que c'est toi qui est très
candide vannes où tu ne vois pas que
tous ces systèmes qui sont développés
vise qu'à une chose ça fait combien
d'années qu'on se connaît
je crois que je suis candidat arrivé car
dix mois que je suis candidat je sais
que tu es loin d'être candidat la guerre
c'est celle des fantômes qu'est ce
qu'ils racontent à eric sadin la guerre
ces salles d'expo méfiez vous expliquer
la guerre si celle de la guerre
industrielle c'est qu'ils aient des
fantômes à côté nous qui nous parlent et
qu'ils nous disent à différents à
différentes échelles les actions à
entreprendre on peut nommer sa camisole
on peut nommer pression peut nommer en
régime en tenant des conduites la
voiture autonome et pourquoi pas le
graal pourquoi google qui étaient dans
leur quête de mots-clés l'information 25
simplement oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils
sont allés faire dans la bagnole mais ça
sert interpellé personne fois de plus
s'est banalisé mais qu'est ce que google
avant ils ont été dans le transport de
personnes hubert et ainsi de suite
plus ou moins mais qu'est ce qu'ils
soient les fers dans l'industrie
automobile mais ça ça n'interpelle
personne vont péter adata vient
exactement alors là je comme dit l'abbé
c'est la marionnette fait vous monsieur
je vais vous le dire il s'agit de mettre
des fantômes dans la voiture c'est à
dire de détenir une tranche une nouvelle
tranche une nouvelle strate
d'intelligibilité de nos comportements
durant les transports c'est beaucoup et
transport à l'échelle de la planète
durant des heures en plus de surcroît
durant des moments on va travailler on
va lire des tablettes on va discuter
interprétation des paroles par des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
avec le langage natural l'interprétation
du langage naturel se joint aussi des
systèmes d'interprétation des
conversations mais aussi c'est pas de la
science fiction ça de la sueur de la
sudation par les sièges donc il s'agit
d'interpréter les comportements google
savent pas faire des bagnoles mais qui
ont donné le ton à toute l'industrie
automobile où il s'agit des dans la
voiture autonome au nom de quoi de la
sécurité supposé mais voit-on le modèle
de société qui est à l'oeuvre qui va
aussi avoir des voitures nous conduire
nous piloter mais pas seulement vous
pilotez s'agit aussi j'ai analysé dans
mon livre pas seulement nous piloter
d'un point passant je tape paris metz de
la façon la plus aiguë sécurisé mais qui
va nous parler la voiture
continuellement nous dire tiens en
fonction de tes historique tu vas aller
dans tel restaurant qui correspond à ton
budget en fonction de l'analyse de ton
visage on va s'arrêter à tal pharmacie
voit-on le seuil du techno libéralisme
qui est à l'oeuvre ou des systèmes vont
nous parler en vue de nous conduire à
plusieurs titres et en vue au cours de
la du pilotage de nous deux de
d'orienter nos comportements et là pour
le coup en vue d'une seule visée en plus
de l'art
lassus régionalisation de la circulation
deux de l'organisation des espaces
urbains en vue de continuellement
procéder à une pression sur sur ma
décision me dire on te connaît tellement
bien eric dans la voiture on te connaît
tellement bien qu'il faut que tu ailles
au vu de ton budget rencontrait telle
personne dentelle le bar très très
approprié à vous deux sur le chemin ou
d'antennes relais et châteaux dentelle
routiers si je n'ai pas un sou c'est
cela le modèle de société
très bon routier à 15 euros voilà c'est
qu'ils ont vraiment abattu mais alors là
peut-être que la voiture autonome les
connais pas encore tu me donneras les
adresses c'est cela c'est cela ce modèle
de saint-etienne-du-grès bon bah tu nous
le dira hors antenne c'est cela le
modèle et tu comprend une fois qu'on a
dit ça on voit bien qu'il ya un modèle
de société qui a une vision du monde et
une vision du monde dont on au nom de
quelques avantages supposés dont on a vu
qu'il fallait voir de près les
conséquences collatérales en général
c'est pas seulement les avantages quand
bien même qu'il faut remettre en
question c'est tout le contexte de ces
supposés avantages que ce que ce que
nous avons fait là en partie donc c'est
cette vision de la société
je pense que là il ya un travail alors
je veux bien croire qu'il est très
compliqué tu as raison j'ai peut-être
perdu et agile essayant d perdu on fait
quoi je ne dit pas s'il est perdu on
fait quoi je dis peut-être n'est-il pas
perdu donc soyons agissant moi j'ai une
équation te dise il est perdu on fait
quoi alors moi j'ai une équation
aujourd'hui elle est très simple on
pourrait presque avoir faire office de
slogans mais c'est pas un slogan pour
moi c'est que plus on ou des saisies de
notre capacité d'action plus on nous
décisive de notre capacité de 2
d'évaluer les choses de nous mêmes de
décider de nous mêmes des actions
entreprendre plus on ne dessaisit de
notre liberté d'agir comme bon nous
semble on insiste peut-être non oui plus
il faut être agissant plus il faut être
et agir dans un téléphone portable oui
mais je n'ai joué que je fais avec mon
téléphone portable plus tu l'entends tu
l'entends cette formule plus on ne
dessaisit de notre faculté
d'agir
il faut être agissant c'est exactement
ça qu'à déterminer l'écriture de mon
livre c'est exactement ça qui les
terminent toutes les paroles que je dis
depuis début tu m'en a fait perdre des
calories un jeu pour être cool comme
heures laurent alexandre regarder sur
smartphone j'ai vu des missions que tu
as fait avec lui en garde françois
ouimet la france est à la traîne
regarder le chinois ils vont nous
bouffer c'est non non moi je parle avec
mes convictions ces messieurs là ces
personnes-là par le non de leur propre
intérêt parce que laurent alexandre il a
des paris les business angels ou non
quelle est sa parole tu sais cette
question naturelle la question d'une
chaîne qui parle qui parle qui parle
quand je parle parce que c'est la
société c'est ma grand mère c'est la
pression que j'ai sociale ou c'est moi
en tant qu individu singulier et libre
qui parle qui parle quand villani nous
dit
que l'ia va être un facteur
d'accroissement de la démocratie mais
quelle honte qui parle c'est ses
intérêts qui parle c'est une vision
techno libéral de l'existence qui parle
quand macron nous dit que qu' il faut
que la france web de l'ia c'est une
vision saint simonienne de l'association
tu viens voter quoi aux prochaines
élections j'ai beaucoup de mal avec le
vote car je crois que de plus en plus je
crois d admis lundi le terme tu as dit
beaucoup de choses avec cézanne enfin
c'est pas que tu as dit beaucoup de
fautes a pointé je crois que de plus en
plus je suis pour la prise en charge
collective mais de façon modeste c'est
pas les grandes manifs des grandes
manifs pour la la
l'assèchement enfin le réchauffement de
la climatique ça me fait rire alors les
bonnes qu'on se dit gouly de bonne
conscience
et juliette binoche des comédiens qui
font une tribune dans le monde contre le
réchauffement climatique me coûter un
corps et lyon lui passe le bonjour nord
mais c'est à mourir de rire ce dégoût
vis de bonne conscience une crue
non je crois que c'est là où là où nous
vivons de nous saisir plutôt que d'avoir
des systèmes qui nous disent
continuellement quoi acheter
construisons d exister chaleureusement
des cycles de distribution des nouvelles
modalités de travail construisions
d'autres d'autres écoles au lieu que au
lieu que l'état investisse dans cette
saloperie de french touch qui bénéficie
de fonds publics qui est une objection
cette french touch en vue de soutenir
toutes les start up mettons l'argent
public pour développer des nouveaux
types d'écoles ou des gens
s'investissent pour
développer d'autres modes d'éducation
que se transformant les professeurs en
tant que coach de plateformes
transformons
créons des centres de soins où il est
pas du diagnostic automatisé loyer de
l'argent public pour accueillir des
personnes en difficulté les personnes
qui n'osent même pas entré dans
l'hôpital des personnes qui ne m'a pas
le
les moyens de se faire suivre
régulièrement mettons l'argent public
dans ce doc dans toutes ses dents de ses
initiatives faisons une pression sur nos
élus pour dire plutôt que de soutenir
les start up earl qui crée d hubert à
tout bout de champ et qu'il ferait des
modalités de management où tout le monde
est supposé être égaux et travaille dans
le coup les titres avec 40 heures par
jour et qui sont mal payés trois sous et
dont on lui dit que c'est laid les
modèles économiques lumineux notre temps
et en vue de monétiser de marchandises
et toute la vie allez vous faire [__]
avec vos start up à vous faire voir et
que cet argent public qu'il soit plutôt
mis à la disposition de citoyens qui
m'ont des nouvelles initiatives
citoyennes qui ne laisse personne
puisqu'on a fait un hasard
bah oui
oui mais là il ya des luttes il ya des
luttes il ya des luttes
emblématique du temps présent mais là on
parle de zad qui est qui et
territoriales je crois que les aides
c'est à toutes les échelles de la
société s'étant donné dans nos esprits
et là je reviens au discours
avons nous les moyens
d'écouter les discours d'hier mais non
le soupçon nietzsche un mois je vais
jouer vos sornettes les écoute pas moi
je les prends pas pour l'argent que
content vos sornettes question
d'internet est ce que tu as déjà été
dans une zad ah non mais si on m'invite
je vais bien y aller je veux bien nous
on a été invité à notre dame des landes
est un truc des gens sympas mais
évidemment mais je dis pas évidemment à
saint parres gestion question d'internet
tu viennes combien en bois
pas beaucoup mais parce que j'ai arrêté
d'enseigner mais je suis libre si vous
voulez que je vous dise en une journée
une seconde que je fais mes journées
gelly j'écris j'ai aucun boss je suis
dans la stricte indépendance je ne roule
pas sur la cdu luxe je sais du que je me
suis construit tiens je vide mes droits
d'auteur mais mes livres se vendent très
bien je suis heureux d'ailleurs quand tu
dis qu'est ce qu'on fait mes livres j'ai
tu sais j'ai une surface de visibilité
et tant mieux et tant mieux ce qu'il est
temps qu'il est contre discours et puis
quand des grands groupes privés car j'y
vais mais invite à donner des
conférences civet pas gratos 1 alors une
question très intéressant dans cette
facture mais conférence mais je dis ce
que j'ai à dire chez orange ou chez
accenture une crise les gens là m'invite
à une question très intéressant à parler
d'internet
est ce la création d'un vrai dieu
l'intelligence artificielle quand il y
avait je me rappelle plus qu' un cadre
chez google qui disait qu'il allait
créer
son dieu avec son hôte et jouit à 5 des
gens parlent de vie dans le bouquin là
je retrouve mon book ajusteur ouais bah
oui oui je veux te dire là l'église
il a terminé la question je peu de
réponses merci monsieur madame ou madame
monsieur magasin
alors y'en a qui présente ça comme ça
non moi je pense c'est pat dieu
l'analogie n'est pas bonne de religion
non c'est un surmoi
tiens c'est un surmoi raison pardon
apaisant un surmoi qui a je reviens à ce
qu'on s'est dit des débuts pour ce qu
ont suivi notre s'appelle une émission
ce qu'ont fait ou notre entretien depuis
le début je reviens à une autre histoire
de vérité c'est un surmoi qui va nous
dire continuellement la vérité des
choses et d'agir en fonction
maintenant il faudrait voir ce que j'ai
dit à plusieurs reprises mais je le
redis une dernière fois il faudrait voir
que le surmoi répond
à des [__] d'intérêt excuse moi
d'être familier en fin d'entretien et à
une vision du monde la vision du monde à
les voir pour ceux qui connaissent le
crédit social chinois taper sur notre
copain google est ce que c'est le crédit
social ou s'il y en a qui veulent voir
qu'est ce qui se joue je renvoie à
mourir ils peuvent l'emprunter aux
bibliothèques ne l'achetez pas
nécessairement ou si vous voulez
l'acheter
ça s'appelle je sais plus trop quoi
l'organisation algorithmique de nos
conduites au bond un chapitre ou
j'analyse ce qui ce qui se jouait ce qui
est en train de se jouer 1 donc oui
c'est ce surmoi
mais ce surmoi où dieu comprenez dieu
dieu en général dans notre présentation
il est bienveillant il de notre bien le
surmoi il veut que répondre à ses
intérêts c'est pour ça que dieu il ya
déjà quelques choi après un présupposé
que c'est pour la bonne chose la bonne
cause douce tout ce discours qu'on
entend depuis un six sept ans thomas de
faire du monde un endroit meilleur tout
c'est tout toutes ces discours encore
dombes de ville va d'emblée avant les
toutes ces trucs dont on est un peu
revenu mais il ya quand même quelque
chose il ya quand même une hygiéniste il
ya quand même un positivisme qui veut
que tous ces développements aller malgré
toutes les critiques malgré toutes les
dérives quand même nous allons vers une
société qui va nous évite des quantités
de défauts d'erreur d'errements que nous
vivons depuis la nuit des temps car
question d'internet on est content de
s'être affranchi de la peste ces
conneries quand même non ah oui mais là
c'était des recherches mais menée par
des médecins menés par des biologistes
menées par des savants interprété en
temps réel mais mes flux physiologique
en vue de continuellement me suggérer
des choses s'est passé là c'est pas de
la recherche médicale c'est beaucoup
plus subtil beaucoup plus sournois
question d'internet est ce qu'une partie
de l'humanité peut survivre en marge du
robot compresseur intelligence
artificielle où tout le monde va y
passer
on la question est intéressante on ne la
posera jamais assez tu me la poser je me
la pose
on se la pose la question c'est en cale
terme nous la posons nous et qui est des
effets de pragmatique
rouleau compresseur puissance on en a
parlé
après c'est là où on parle de quoi on
parle de la responsabilité
ch et lycées la responsabilité de chacun
est ce que tu as envie c'était de telles
personnes que je tutoie l'un reconnaît
idem mais la question mais déjà
sympathique il ya un lien de fraternité
dans cette question est-ce que tu
acceptes que des systèmes te dise
continuellement coiffeur et à des
niveaux de plus en plus coercitives
est-ce que tu acceptes que des systèmes
comme en chine vont dénoncer les
conduites au profit d'un évier nice mme
cissé si c'est non alors il faut être
agissant il faut à dire certains
systèmes on n'en veut pas est ce que tu
as vu le film l'homme bicentenaire alors
des buts je les ai vus rappelle moi
parce que j'ai oublié moi j'oublie tous
les films que je vois j'apprécie une
sale histoire d'un d'un robot qui veut
devenir humain oui dans une famille
ouais et comment ça se termine comme il
est jeté par la fenêtre non ça se
termine on va pas se poser merde
ça craint
rené mois
il veut mourir comme un homme donc il
invente un système où il peut se
dégrader et en fait avoir une dame en
fait c'est son ultime recherche c'est
l'âme donc ma question qui est une
question internet
si le passage du point de singularité
est inévitable at il une autre idée
alternative que celle de musk qui est de
fusionner avec
oui non mais tout cela encore là c'est
d'abord moi si je réponds à cela c'est
comme s'ils prenaient au sérieux toutes
ces conneries là la fusion la
singularité enfin que ça c'est une sorte
de 2 commence à de sauce de tellement
loin de la réalité tellement loin de ce
qui se passe
comme si aux la singularité le bon on
est dans l'idée de
on est dans le moment trop paume
orphique de la technique 1 qui voudrait
que les systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle sont modélisés sur le
cerveau humain ce qui était à l'oeuvre
avec la cybernétique dont on n'a jamais
assez relevé que toutes les personnes
qui avaient tenté de concevoir ces
systèmes aucun ne relevez des sciences
du vivant des sciences cognitives
c'était tous des ingénieurs des
matteotti mathématicien des techniciens
de qu'ils avaient une vision du cerveau
extrêmement lacunaires
cinquante ans plus tard c'est le rêve
cybernétique et entend être à l'oeuvre
c'est quoi le raid cybernétique c'est
alors que ces personnes il ya 50 ans
dans les années 50 et 60 il ya plus de
50 ans maintenant après la catastrophe
de de la deuxième guerre mondiale dont
beaucoup l'étonnant la cybernétique
c'est l'histoire que tout le monde
connait je crois aujourd'hui
venez des pays de l'est avaient dû fuir
le nazisme se sont posé la question
comment la technique qui peut créer une
telle catastrophe hiroshima elles
pourraient être exploitées utilisé dans
son effet inverse en vue d'instaurer une
organisation plus pacifié de la société
c'est ça la cybernétique et pour cela
ils ont imaginé ce sont dix c'est
étrange dans l'histoire des idées
d'histoires la technique d'imaginer que
pour tenter de donner un cours
supposé positif à la technique il
fallait modéliser des systèmes sur les
cerveaux ims très très surprenant on
sait pas assez arrêté sur cette histoire
des idées et en supposant que
c'était fondé sur le postulat que le
cerveau constitue un système
extraordinaire de d'organisation de
l'information ce qui est le cas et de
l'appréhension du réel bon alors qu'est
ce qu'il s'est passé c'est que le rêve
le fanta cybernétique qui est
extrêmement bidu extrêmement ambivalent
un caïd il aspirait une organisation
pacifié mais aussi père fait de la
société sauf que dans les années 50 et
60 et l'état la technique ne pouvait
répondre à leurs aspirations ni les
moyens financiers étaient présents pour
pour se tenir ces recherches ce qui
s'est passé c'est une numérisation de la
société et une rationalisation par
l'informatisation de la société ne
société et puis se trouve qu'un début
des années 2010 un peu avant avec
l'apparition des systèmes experts il y
avait déjà la puissance d' expertise qui
a commencé à être apparaître au cours
des années 90 au début des années 2010
il ya le modèle neuronale qui est qui a
été réintroduit pour le système qui une
fois de plus et développé par des
ingénieurs décodeurs des programmeurs
des mathématiciens dont yann le cas ce
modèle neuronale qui est donc qu'il ne
relève absolument dont il n'y a aucun
spécialiste des sciences du cerveau donc
c'est un peu un modèle neuronale
extrêmement lacunaires c'est une idée du
cerveau fondée sur des structures
connexio nist fondée sur
sûr alors aujourd'hui il ya des termes
très enjoliveurs de la technique on
parle de il ya tout un neuro lexique qui
s'est développée depuis synaptique de
processeurs de renault donc il faut voir
qu'est-ce que c'est difficile est ce que
ça qu'à intelligence artificielle
qu'est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle terre les termes les
discours le langage qu'est ce que ça
cache cela ou qu'est ce que ça apporte
plutôt que cacher sa porte un modèle de
société où toutes les affaires c'est
très important ce que j'utilise très
important qui est en lien avec tout ce
qu'on dit depuis le début ça cache la
volonté d'ériger un modèle de société
fondé sur continuellement l'extrême
activité du cerveau la structuration des
affaires humaines à l'intérieur d'une
organisation connexio nist du chose un
modèle vitalis tous les choses
fonctionnent continuellement et sans
arrêt une modèle de perfection de
l'organisation de l'information et
d'appréhension du réel etc ces personnes
qui développent des systèmes fondés sur
son supposé fondé de façon extrêmement
lacunaires sur nos cerveaux humains et
bien véhicule ce modèle de société
ultra réactif continuellement dynamique
c'est pour ça que le terme intelligence
artificielle
il s'agirait aussi de le remettre en
question de voir que nous n'avons en
aucune manière en aucune manière à faire
à une intelligence artificielle mais
nous avons à faire un mode de
rationalité c'est ce que j'ai analysé
dans mon livre dans mon livre ou jeudi
précisément les choses un mode de
rationalité fondée sur l'extrême
rationalisation des choses sur la
volonté de marchandises est
continuellement l'existence et
d'instaurer 7,8 tilly tarissement
généralisée à ce mode de rationalité il
s'agirait de faire valoir et c'est là
nous revenons à nos zad n'est ce pas
d'autres modes de rationalité faisons
sur la presse fondée sur l'appréhension
multisensorielle du réel fondés sur
l'expression de la pluralité humaine car
ces systèmes sont des systèmes
d'homogénéisation des modes
d'organisation d'existence donc cette
affaire de singularité qui suppose que
nos cerveaux vont pouvoir à l'intérieur
de cette
réductionnisme pour pouvoir comme dit le
querrec on va tous ces gens très
intelligents les comprimés qui relève de
la psychiatrie ces gens là sont fous
sont des malades qui rêvent de la
tranche humaniste et qui rêve de la
singularité faut voir la tronche tison
car ils font tous s'ils ont tous l'air
plus de deux secondes vers tous
déglingué et il nous parle de
l'immortalité physique ouais bon mais
alors que le la durée de la vie pour la
première fois depuis un siècle elle
commence à se raccourcir un qui nous
promettent une mortalité comment sous
lequel modalités en type croit on s'est
connus dans ces années ces inepties et
l'équipe croire ça ça fait des unes de
magazines en promettant de télécharger
le cerveau sur des puces de silicium et
mon dieu comme si le cerveau humain
l'objet le plus complexes au monde qui
titille qui fonctionne par une
appréhension
multisensorielle du réel par le corps
par les sens par la vue pas lui qui est
doté d'une mémoire intra-utérine la
noire de tous les événements de la vie
mais qui peut croire mais comment même
peut-on énoncé avoir l'audace l'autre
quid ans
dénoncé que et bien à terme le cerveau
vous pouvoir être réduit des lignes de
co2 qui téléchargent c'est toujours des
puces de 7 à 10 jours ce qui sauvera
l'humanité non et c'est peut-être ce qui
soude à bord c'est impossible j'ose
affirmer ici que c'est un peu car ces
personnes avez vous remarqué comme
l'aileron alexandre et comme tant
d'autres nous parle de la société ou
futurs ah non ça suffit cela ça suffit
de nous parler de la société au futur
comme si les choses est écrit et très en
avance
ne sont pas écrites à l'avance les
choses doivent être envisagés ou présent
en mettant en la terre d'une mise en
perspective historique c'est à dire d'où
ça vient d'où ça vient commence à
s'opérer au présent et c'est aux
présents que nous devons évaluer les
choses et aux présents que nous devons
être agissant arrêtons de nous raconter
le futur comme il doit être écrit par le
mont technique aux industriels arrêtons
comment lui et le monde doit être écrire
la terre d'une logique dé l'inéluctable
et confrontent on nous aurait elle au
présent et arrêtons de gober des
sornettes du transhumanisme et de et du
téléchargement de nos cerveaux qui est
une sorte de délire total et prenons
prenons ces paroles
respectifs vis ça doit pas non c'est pas
du tout la même chose d'être
prospectiviste et de nous raconter que à
terme tous les défauts d'existence vont
être éradiquée au profit de nora ligne
par exemple depuis ce dans le cerveau le
système qui vont continuer mais c'est
quoi ce système qui vont continuellement
nous est dicté la bonne la bonne action
entreprendre envisageons
examinons de près par qui sont produites
tout ces paroles à quel intérêt ça
répond calmement de société ça instaure
et au présent travail on a analysé le
réel qui scandent qui en train de se
constituer pour faire valoir quoi notre
humanité mais d'autres mais d'autres
futurs possibles mais pour cela il faut
être agi sans fard et et de gober ces
sornettes et ça c'est très compliqué à
cette puissance c'est un moment j'ai dit
on est dans l'ère de la puissance à
cette puissance la faire valoir d'autres
puissances alors je vais bien encore
dire redire
ces vins que c'est peut-être le combat
est perdu mais oui alors mais l'appui sa
face à la puissance massive qui a un
truc intéressant face à la puissance
massive les indiens on a parlé des
faisons valoir la puissance nucléaire
multiples puissance nucléaire au sens du
nombre d'atomes à toutes les échelles de
la sutie savions agissant
faisons valoir d'autres modalités
possibles house est par exemple voilà
c'est si les médecins sont agissant ça
changera le cours inéluctable de la
transformation digitale et hôpitaux et
avec tout l'argent public est jeté par
la fenêtre avec tout le corps médical
qui les prospectivistes c'est quoi pour
toi prospective et ça aussi ce que je
fais
prospectiviste c'est avoir du nez c'est
à dire saisir les signaux faibles et
tisser les liens entre les signaux
faibles et voir ce qui est les
intentions qui sont en train d'être
construites les trajectoires qui sont en
cours et des futurs possibles c'est ce
que je fais
être idéologue du futur c'est supposer
qu'à des signes forts et les prendre
comme inéluctable et comme étant écrit à
l'avancé pas du tout la jfpi d'une
petite pique alors lixon mais si si avec
eux à leur laurent alexandre 1 qui je
leur dis des conneries sur conneries ce
monsieur peut me faire un procès il ya
beaucoup plus de pognon que moi mais je
dirai ce que je pense c'est à dire
d'abord il écrit c'est des torchons qui
les crises pas des livres sont essayés
discuter avec lui mais je le connais
bien je connais très bien on a fait
quelques débats ansa mais depuis que qui
parle mais qui ne cesse de parler dia en
disant qu'il ya on est en retard et
c'est là je suis un peu agacé je ne suis
pas je crois que si on parle ce sera
extrêmement conflictuel 1 parce que
voilà un monsieur qui parle à partir de
ses intérêts je veux qu'on organisait un
débat entre toi et lui si moi je crois
que je préférerais un débat avec cédric
villani parce qu'il est élu de la
république on appelle à mai et je sais
pas s'il acceptera car tu as vu j'ai des
arbres de rhétorique et des arbres
d'arguments et pas bête villani g et je
ne dis jamais dit qu'il était bête tous
ces gens là je n'ai jamais dit que
laurent alexandre était bête il est loin
d'être bête j'ai jamais dit que y'a
mieux qu'un été bête mais tous ces gens
là portent une idéologie porte des
intérêts par une vision du monde un mois
je défend des principes humanistes la
dignité l'intégrité humaine la volonté
de le refus de soumettre
toutes les actions humains dans la
marchandisation intégral le refus
d'organiser des façons en rythmique et
il extrait mais de façon réaliste la
société voilà ma mon rapport au réel qui
n'est pas du tout le même et là il ya un
conflit de position il ya un conflit de
perception il ya un conflit de vision du
monde ici de le cuivre soit si tu veux
appeler viviani en direct n'hésite pas
mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils veuillent
débattre avec moi je sais quel est
l'intérêt de vie d'annie à débattre avec
moi tu veux me dire lui qui assoit son
discours avec des journalistes qui bob
qui gobent ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
gueulent qui gobent tout ce qu'il dit et
bien pour une fois il y aura quelqu'un
qui se confrontera à ce qu'il dit il n'y
a aucun intérêt mais aucun nom je
l'appellerai après
en revanche la société aurait intérêt à
ce que y ait des débats conflictuels des
débats frontaux avec ces personnes et
quand une émission télé qui va passer
sur un paris première à ce prochain
propose un débat avec quelqu'un et qui
refusent en disant qu en dix ans izzy
pas je veux pas débattre avec eric sadin
ou non il dit je fais pas de politique
mais cette extraordinaire puisque
villani fait de la politique débattons
de la politique des développements
techno techno industrielle développée
évoquons l'impact politique promis la
portée politique reprises que c'est un
politique et moi avec mes paroles on a
compris que je parle de technique mais
je parle d'économie et je parle aussi
pas seulement je parle je parle et je
fais oeuvre de politiques à ma parole
thomas parle je vais l'appeler ça sera
compliqué pour vous d'organiser un
dialogue un débat c'est très sain en
toute cordialité et cédric villani très
cordiale la mémoire ce souci
mais il n'y a aucun intérêt parce qu'il
n'y en ait à confronter pour affronter
où il ne voit que des personnes tu lui
font des courbettes en disant c'est
formidable ce que vous dites ça se voit
moins dans les yeux des journalistes qui
écrit des rapports ou les conclusions
des rapports sont reçus avec des grands
sourires partout les journalistes de la
france est pas donc il n'y a aucun
aucune dimension de critiques
relativement ce qu'il énonce ce serait
la première personne qu'il aurait en
face de lui avec des arguments vous avez
vu que j'ai de quoi
énoncé décrit précisément ce qui ce jour
aura-t-il et le courage la bravoure et
les moyens d'entretenir un vrai dialogue
de politique citoyen je l'espère
maintenant la balle est dans son camp
moi j'y suis prêt eh ben on vit avec
yann le cas aussi mais il a déjà donné
sa réponse ont voulu passer messages on
arrive à la fin presque la fin de notre
notre format on peut continuer un peu
des choses à rajouter
je vais peut-être regarder de trois
jours moi je n'ai on a dit beaucoup de
choses à j'ai juste un petit
une petite il ya de petites choses que
j'aimerais bien rajouter
je voudrais qu'il ait pas de confusion
sur un point je sais que vous êtes très
proche de la quadrature du net ici c'est
très propre moi je jérémie zimmermann
que tu as invité je connais bien on se
tutoie on a passé des soirées ensemble à
lisbonne des conférences et dans
d'autres endroits non monsieur quelqu'un
qui met tout à fait sympathique
mais je me pose farouchement à ces gens
là où hanter les cages opère un
distinguo
très nette car avez vous remarqué
aujourd'hui
que quand on veut faire preuve de
vigilance supposé face à tout ce que
nous avons annoncé on en revient
sempiternel mans semble éternellement à
la question des données personnelles
delà du pillage de la vie privée de la
surveillance questions sur lesquelles
j'ai travaillé plus de dix ans pour ma
part j'avais publié un livre en 2009
donc j'avais commencé à travailler en
2006 qui s'appelait surveillance globale
qui était vu bien 2009 sous titres
enquête sur une nouvelle forme de
contrôle publié chez flammarion à
l'époque tout le monde disait t'es pas
été pas un peu paranoïaque il ya eu ce
modèle en 2013 là j'étais invité par la
presse toute la presse en france a
signalé a précisé ce qui se joue est
donc je dis pas que je suis insensible à
ça c'était j'ai très tôt j'ai analysé
l'intelligible d'éditer des
comportements
la trace le traçage des des
comportements privés je dis aujourd'hui
que si cela existe ce n'est plus du tout
le problème ce n'est plus du tout
problème le problème c'est ce qu'on a
évoqué ses à l'orientation de l'action
humaine
c'est le dessaisissement de l'autonomie
de la faculté jugement de la liberté de
décider de nos actions individuellement
et collectives et collectivement le set
cette focalisation sur les données
privées ça suppose également à l'image
notre temps c'est une fois qu'on navigue
conserve sur les réseaux à l'abri des
regards doute d'autrui ou je bénéficie
de ma petite supposé
vie privée
le tour est joué mais c'est allemand à
l'image de l'individualisme qu'on peut
mourir je ne dis pas que ce sont pas des
questions importantes mais il serait
temps de se soucier de questions de
liberté dans les modes d'organisation en
commun d'intégrité de dignité humaine de
marchandisation intégrale de la vie
voilà il serait temps de se suicider de
cela et puis je quand on parlait de
crédit social je vais évoquer un brevet
qui est alors qui dit quand même ce qui
est dans la tête il ya un film dans la
tête john malkovich coin qui est dans la
tête de certains concepteurs est ce que
vous avez entendu parler j'en parle dans
mon livre parce que cette extraordinaire
sur ce que se permet la recherche est ce
que se permettent les chercheurs
aujourd'hui on a parlé de amazon des
systèmes et dicte au personnel ou bien
on en a parlé longuement est ce que
j'avais entendu parler d'un bracelet un
brevet bracelet qui n'est pas encore mis
sur le marché qui viserait à pour les
personnes qui le porterait s'ils sont
supposés en fonction de critères doivent
être posés sur la main si la main est
dans le mauvais endroit écoutez bien ce
que je veux dire dans régime lentement
des conduites
laura qu'on accorde l'intelligence
artificielle ce monsieur a dit eudes
yeux un divinité moi je parle de surmoi
sur moi de vérité à le dire la vérité à
tous qu'en toute chose et à nos corriger
et bien ce bracelet qui a été breveté
qui n'est pas encore mis sur le marché
est-ce qu'on voit ce que ça signale et
bien en fonction de la triangulation des
geôles acquis lisation si le mas main ma
main d'êtres humains et au mauvais
endroit il est repris et va là où il
doit aller dans le dans les étagères de
stock voyez-vous l'abjection ça c'est
que l'intelligence artificielle
voyez-vous la gestion et la courbe que
ça signal et ça c'est le résultat direct
de ce qui est nommé innovations
numériques ces résultats directs
d'exploitation qui est possible avec
l'intelligence artificielle --six au nom
de tels développements qu'on nous dit
quoi la france est en retard mais la
france pays historiques et une vieille
histoire c'est une fable aujourd'hui des
droits de l'homme se serait tout son
honneur de dire ses modèles là on n'en
veut pas et on développe d'autres
modèles économiques plutôt nous raconter
continuellement à la laurent alexandre
qu'on est en retard et qui voudra
investir davantage investis sont
davantage pour refuser des bracelets qui
décide sans qu'on ait le mot le la
liberté la subjectivité de décider de
nous amener ailleurs mais c'est pas moi
qui dois scandalisé c'est chaque être
humain qui tient sa liberté à sa liberté
de conscience et à sa faculté de décider
par son autonomie le jugement et perd sa
liberté du cours des choses je crois que
nous ne voyons pas qu'au delà les
supposés avantages sur lesquels nous
avons vu que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça a ses avantages que
nous ne voyons pas le cours des affaires
humaines qui est dessinée qui se dessine
là c'est les signaux faibles et les
signes forts tient leur régiment des
conduites par l'intelligence
artificielle et cette intelligence à
thiviers dont mounir medjoubi
qui nous dit quoi je comprends que
industriels développent et qu'on
réfléchira après monsieur
secrétaire d'état numérique honte à vous
non seulement on doit réfléchir
maintenant mais ça doit faire l'objet de
débats publics voilà une personne qui je
pourrais aussi me poser dans le débat
public et c'est pas aux industriels de
décider du cours de nos sociétés c'est à
toute la société entière de décider du
cours individuels et collectifs de nos
destins et arrêtons d'instituer une
société où c'est le monde industriel qui
décident à notre place la façon des
choses doivent être organisées c'est une
honte absolue et vous vous êtes indigne
représentants et élus de la république
c'est ce que je crois trois livres a
conseillé
pardon
est-ce que tu as trop livre à conseiller
notre communauté mon dernier livre d'un
nouveau nissan a pas le droit bon alors
george orwell
politique de la langue anglaise les
discours les discours se méfier des
discours ayant nous on va renouer avec
le politique quand on aura rejoint
renouer avec une hygiène de la langue
hier toute cette pollution discours là
toutes ces discours préformaté toute
cette doxa ce travestissement d'une
française tout ce que cette prise de
contrôle de la dialectique absolument
toutes ses lignes de magazines d'où le
pôle it is for media politis et une de
magazines du parc de magasiner
formidable j'ai pas dit ça c'était une
de magazines
hannah arendt il faut relire hannah
arendt qui dit que l'autonomie du entend
bien j'ai pas tu m'a entendu parler
souvent d'autonomie du logement hannah
arendt grande philosophe la plus grande
philosophe du politique du xxème siècle
qui avec le nazisme fall qui a fui avant
heureusement
qui a vu les dégâts a dit nazisme par sa
famille parce qu'elle a vécu et qui est
allé avant aux états unis ce que n'a pas
pu faire benyamine qui est mort avant
d'arriver aux états unis
la même génération de philosophe
allemand qui a dit que c'est l'autonomie
de jugement qui conditionne politique
c'est l'autonomie jugement qui a la
faculté à évaluer singulièrement les
choses et dire ça on veut on ne veut pas
mais allez dire autre chose qui
conditionnent nos politiques c'est la
pluralité humaine tiers c'est toute la
société dans sa pluralité dans des
intérêts diverses dans le conflit dans
la contradiction qui conditionne la
politique on le sait système
d'intelligence artificielle c'est la
liquidation du politique dr.web
arendt
le dirait jacques ellul puisque mon
livre est une citation de jacques ellul
puisque mon livre s'intitule mon nouveau
livre s'intitule l'intelligence
artificielle où les enjeux du siècle qui
est une citation d'un livre du grand
jacques ellul la technical enjeux du
siècle qu'il avait écrit en 1954 à
l'écart de tout le verbiage mais toffees
métaphysico aux marxistes de l'époque et
qui avait déjà vu que développement
technique était orienté déterminé par le
monde économique
et que ça crée quoi sacré quoi ça crée
des structures asymétrique de pouvoir
notamment dans le monde du travail
notamment dans la faculté l'entreprise
du monde économique a organisé le cours
des sociétés de façon extrêmement
rationaliser il avait pas été écoutés à
l'époque pourquoi il n'avait pas écouté
à l'époque ce que c'était au moment des
trente glorieuses oui avec l'idéologie
du progrès qui était flamboyante et qui
occupait tout le terrain les discours
c'est très intéressant de voir que le
grand jacques ellul et relu aujourd'hui
il est remis à la mode dont certains
milieux notamment chez nombre de existe
donc c'est pour ça que mon livre est une
citation du livre déjà qu'élu la
technique où l'enjeu du siècle ce qui
sort ce que je crois que plus que jamais
il faut voir de quoi est constitué la
technique aujourd'hui et ne pas être
dupe sur la volonté du mont technique
aux industriels politiques a décidé le
coup résistance au nom de leurs proies
présenté 16 quitté reprocher par
certains que tu fasses
référence d'autres auteurs et que tu les
agrège dans tes bouquins et que je vois
pas quoi au nom de quoi menons je cite
c'est la citation c'est le lien c'est le
lien avec les autres le lien avec
l'histoire le lien je fais des citations
et heureusement et je convoque orwell je
convoque un arendt et je convoque chacun
d'eux dans autant pas beaucoup parce que
les traits dans les données privées etc
je le sais maintenant ça ne m'intéresse
beaucoup moins qu'avant
mais c'est quelqu'un qui m'est
sympathique morose à la fin
on a en revanche ses ingénieurs qui
écrit ses bouquins le parlant des tic
annonça jolies pages que je les cite
même pas donc on arrive à la fin la
dernière question n'est pas une question
s'est laissé une bouteille à la mer un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
ne pas être groupe est dans le soupçon
[Musique]
moi je me dis je suis philosophe
critique j'affirme aussi comme talent
auteur critique
plus que jamais c'est quand on est ado
qu'est ce qu'on fait un moment met en
doute les paroles des parents on met en
doute n'est parole de la société parfois
de façon impulsive et non fondées je
crois qu'il faut renouer à et canaliser
enfin canaliser c'est à dire sur des
bons sujets sur des bons objets cette
faculté à remettre en doute à remettre
en deux et les avis qu'est-ce qui se
puisse que tu as parlé à distance j'y
reviens ce sont des personnes qui
remettent en doute des modes des paroles
mais là où ils sont là oui là ou là où
l'honneur et de l'autre de leur côté
c'est que c'est en actions ce qui se
donne les moyens il a les moyens de dire
ses modèles à deux sociétés on ne roule
pas ericsson merci merci
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]